COULD ASK YOU TO TAKE YOUR SEATS --
WE OBVIOUSLY -- DON'T HAVE A A
QUORUM PRESENT YET BUT WE WON'T
LET THAT.
LITTLE DETAIL HOLD US BACK -- WE
WILL -- PUT THE AYE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR OVER UNTIL WE DO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND BEGAN AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE -- WITH.
ISSUE ONE UNDER ITEMS TO BE
HEARD -- WHICH IS CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION SEE THAT THE
MISTRANSLATED HERE WITH HIS CREW
SO IF YOU WOULD ALL STEP FORWARD.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH THE ISSUE ONE
WHICH IS AN INFORMATIONAL.
HEARING -- TO GIVE US UPDATED
INFORMATION ON THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY AUTHORITY
AND AND ENFORCEMENT.
WELCOME EVERYONE GOOD MORNING.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I'M JACK GAINES WORTH EXECUTIVE
RECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
COMMISSION AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY IS -- LISA HAGEE WHO IS --
ONE OF MY DEPUTY DIRECTORS IN
CHARGE OF OUR ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION AT LEAST WILL BE
PROVIDING.
YOUR REPORT ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION OR ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES AUTHORITY FOR COASTAL
ACCESS VIOLATIONS WHICH WAS
INCLUDED IN OUR STATUTE FIVE
YEARS AGO SO ALTERNATE OVER THE
LEASE AT THIS POINT.
THE MORNING GERMAN BLOOM
COMMITTEE TODAY WERE PLEASED TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH KEY FINDINGS --
FROM THE COSTA COMMISSIONS
JANUARY FIFTEEN REPORT ON THE
USE OF ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES
TO RESOLVE COASTAL ACT
VIOLATIONS INVOLVING PUBLIC
ACCESS.
AS AUTHORIZED BY PUBLIC
RESOURCES CODE THREE WAIT.
TWENTY ONE WHEN THE LEGISLATURE
CONFERRED THIS AUTHORITY ON THE
COMMISSION IN THE BUDGET ACTIVE
TWENTY FOURTEEN YOU ALSO
REQUIRED US TO REPORT BACK ON
OUR IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS.
WE SUBMIT COPIES OF THE FULL
REPORT WHICH IS ALSO AVAILABLE
ON OUR WEBSITE.
SO THIS MORNING I JUST GONNA DO
A BRIEF OVERVIEW AND BE
AVAILABLE FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE.
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES AS YOU
MAY KNOW OUR STANDARD
ENFORCEMENT TOOL USED BY
VIRTUALLY ALL STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DETER AND
RESOLVE CODE VIOLATIONS WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO TO COURT.
BECAUSE THE COSTA LIKE TO
STARKLY LOCKED LACK THIS
AUTHORITY OUR ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS HAD BEEN MUCH LESS
EFFICIENT THAN THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE.
WITH NO THREAT OF FINANCIAL
PENALTY.
INTENSE LITIGATION IS A SLOW AND
EXPENSIVE MEANS TO COMPEL
COMPLIANCE AND COLLECT PENALTIES
IT WAS NOT UNCOMMON FOR SOME
VIOLATIONS TO PROTECT.
PERSIST FOR DECADES OR MORE
WITHOUT RESOLUTION.
CONSEQUENTLY THE COMMISSION'S
OPEN BACKLOG OF UNRESOLVED
VIOLATIONS IS GOING TO TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED WITH MORE
BEING ADDED EACH YEAR.
SECTION THROUGH A TWENTY ONE NOW
ENABLES THE COMMISSION TO ASSESS
PENALTIES FOR PUBLIC ACCESS
VIOLATIONS DIRECTLY.
WHICH SAVE SIGNIFICANT
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR THE
COMMISSION THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND THE COURTS THEMSELVES IT
ALSO PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE FOR
VIOLATORS TO AVOID FINES BY
SETTLING VOLUNTARILY.
WHICH LEVELS THE PLAYING FIELD
BETWEEN THOSE WHO FOLLOW THE LAW
AND THOSE WHO CHOOSE TO IGNORE
IT.
THE DATA WE'VE COMPILED OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS HAS ALLOWED US
TO COMPARE THE RELATIVE
EFFECTIVENESS AND READ A
RESOLUTION FOR CLOSE TO LIKE
VIOLATIONS WITH AND WITHOUT
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY AUTHORITY.
OUR CURRENT PUBLIC ACCESS OF
CASELOAD IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO CASES OR ROUGHLY 30%
OF THE CURRENT BACKLOG OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED OPEN
VIOLATIONS.
BECAUSE THIS IS MORE THAN WE
COULD OP PROCESS THAT ONE TIME
WITH THEIR CURRENT STAFFING
LEVELS WE INITIALLY CONCENTRATED
ON THE PILOT PROJECT OF A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN CASES.
NOTIFYING THOSE PROPERTY OWNERS
THAT THE VIOLATIONS WERE NOW
SUBJECT TO THE POTENTIAL FINES
UNDER THE NEW LAW.
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS THE THIRTY DAY
GRACE PERIOD FOR PROPERTY OWNERS
TO RESOLVE THE VIOLATIONS
VOLUNTARILY AND COMPLETELY AVOID
A PENALTY WE'RE PLEASED TO FIND
THAT MANY PARTIES WERE WILLING
TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF THIS.
AND COMPLY QUICKLY IN ORDER TO
AVOID PENALTIES IN FACT BECAUSE
OF OUR STAFFING CONSTRAINTS WE
EXTENDED THE THIRTY DAYS IN MANY
CASES WHEN WE HAVE PARTIES WERE
WILLING TO SETTLE.
AND FOR THEIR ACCOMMODATED MORE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WILLING TO
COOPERATE.
SO AS A RESULT IN NINETY SIX OF
THE INITIAL ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN CASES OR MORE THAN
70% OF OUR INITIAL TARGET
UNIVERSE WERE RESOLVED AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL WITH NO PENALTIES
AT ALL.
SOME OF THESE VIOLATIONS HAVE
BEEN PREVIOUSLY PERSISTING FOR
MANY YEARS WITH NO MOVEMENT
TOWARDS COMPLIANCE DESPITE
EFFORTS BY COMMISSION STAFF.
IN EACH OF THESE VIOLATIONS THAT
REMAINED IN PLACE FOR YEARS HAD
A CON COMMITMENT THE LACK OF
PUBLIC ACCESS FOR THE PUBLIC.
EIGHT CASES REQUIRED FORMAL
COMMISSION ACTION BECAUSE OF THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THE VIOLATIONS
THE NATURE OF THE WORK RESULT
REQUIRED TO RESOLVE THEM OR THE
PARTY'S REFUSAL TO SETTLE. SIX
OF THOSE EIGHT WERE SETTLED
THROUGH CONSENT ORDERS WHICH
WERE AGREED TO BY ALL THE
PARTIES RESULTING IN
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT SIX
MILLION IN PENALTIES AND
PROJECTS.
SOME OF THESE PAYMENTS HAVE
ALREADY EEN DEAD DESIGNATED TO
FOR THE COASTAL ACTS PUBLIC
ACCESS GOALS. FOR EXAMPLE A
PORTION OF A PENALTY PAID BY A
RESTAURANT IN SAN MATEO COUNTY
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED TO FIND
PRELIMINARY WORK FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF AN AXIS WAY
ADMITTED MONTERO STATE BEACH.
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS WILL BE
FUNDED WHEN PENALTIES ARE
APPROPRIATED AND AVAILABLE IN
THE VR A TOTAL WE'VE RESOLVED
HUNDRED AND TWO OF OUR ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN NOTICED
CASES AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
NEGOTIATING ON THE REMAINDER.
ONLY TWO OF THE INITIAL GROUP OF
ONE HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
VIOLATIONS HAVE RESULTED
MEDICATION WHICH IS A VERY.
LOW RATE INMUCH LOWER THAN THE
RATE -- PRIOR TO THE EGGMAN
PENALTIES.
A REVIEW OF OUR PUBLIC ACCESS
CASES SHOWS THAT HISTORICALLY IT
TOOK AN AVERAGE OF ONE THOUSAND
SEVENTY THREE DAYS TO RESOLVE A
PUBLIC ACCESS CASE WHICH IS A
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEARS.
IN CONTRAST AFTER ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES THE AVERAGE TIME TO
RESOLVE THE CASE IS NOW A
HUNDRED ANDTWO DAYS OR ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE MONTHS.
MORE THAN A QUARTER OF THESE OR
27% SORRY BUT OF THE NUMBERS BUT
THERE RESULT IN THIRTY DAYS OR
LESS AND ANOTHER FORTY TWO ARE
RESOLVED BETWEEN THIRTY IN A
HUNDRED DAYS.
IT'S ACTUALLY A STUNNING OUTCOME
IT'S MUCH BETTER THAN WE
EXPECTED THE POTENTIAL FOR FINES
WITHOUT EVEN COLLECTING THEM
RESULTED IN 69% OF NOTIFIED
VIOLATIONS RESOLVING WITHIN A
HUNDRED DAYS.
AS OPPOSED TO THE THREE YEARS
PREVIOUSLY.
OF COURSE PUBLIC ACCESS
VIOLATIONS ARE NOT THE ONLY TYPE
OF VIOLATION WE SEE IF YOU
COMPARE AVERAGE RESOLUTION TIMES
FOR THREE AWAIT TWENTY WENT
ACCESS CASES WITH NON PUBLIC
ACCESS CASES IT'S EVEN MORE
DRAMATIC.
DURING THE STATUTORY REPORTING
PERIOD OF TWENTY FIFTEEN TO
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE AVERAGE
LENGTH OF TIME TO RESOLVE IT
THROUGH EIGHT TWENTY AND ONE
CASE WAS A HUNDRED AND TWO DAYS.
COMPARED TO ONE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR DAYS FOR
OVER FIVE YEARS INVOLVING
HABITAT CASES.
FINALLY I JUST WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A GENERAL IDEA OF THE
BENEFITS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE TO THE PUBLIC USING
THESE PENALTIES.
THE COMMISSION IS RESOLVED
IMPEDIMENTS AND OPEN UP ACCESS
WAYS IN TWENTY CASES RESULT
FORTY TWO CASES OF ILLEGAL NO
PARKING AND ILLEGAL NO
TRESPASSING SIGNS.
WE'VE NEGOTIATED DIRECT PUBLIC
BENEFITS SUCH AS A SIGNALIZED
CROSSWALK ACROSS PCH IN MALIBU.
IMPROVEMENTS TO AN EXISTING
TRAIL NETWORK YNET IN NEWPORT
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC ACCESS
AMENITIES INCLUDING BENCHES
SIGNAGE BIKE RACKS EVEN
BINOCULARS AND A PUBLIC LAND
DONATIONS AND TO COMMITMENTS TO
OPEN TRAIL SEGMENTS THAT WILL
ADD MISSING PIECES TO THE
COASTAL TRAIL.
THE TAKE AWAY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE IS THAT
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY OF
AUTHORITY IS PROVING TO BE AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR RESOLVING
MORE PUBLIC ACCESS CASES MORE
QUICKLY.
IT'S ENABLED COMMISSION STAFF IN
THAT IT WILLING PARTIES TO
RESOLVE VIOLATIONS WITHOUT
FORMAL LEGAL ACTION WHICH SAVES
EVERYONE TIME REMAINING AS A
RESULT THE PUBLIC NOW IS ACCESS
TO MORE COASTAL AREAS UP AND
DOWN THE COAST.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PRESENTATION
WERE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU OTHER STATISTICS ARE
PRETTY REMARKABLE --
CONGRATULATIONS -- BUT YOU KNOW
WE I REMEMBER WHEN WE
IMPLEMENTED THIS POLICY AND
THERE WAS SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
TO WIN IT WOULD -- WE HAD A
REALLY STRONG INDICATION THAT IT
WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL BUT DIDN'T
KNOW THAT WOULD BE.
THE SUCCESSFUL -- ONE OF THE
PERHAPS SMALLER BUT VERY
PERSISTENT VIOLATIONS THAT WE'VE
SEEN OVER THE YEARS IS --
PRIVATE PROPERTY OWNERS PUTTING
UP NO PARKING SIGNS IN THE LIKE
ON PUBLIC PROPERTY -- IN AREAS
WHERE THE PUBLIC IS -- A
PERMITTED TO PARK -- THAT THAT
THAT SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THE
TOUGHER TYPE OF VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE IT.
WHAT WANT TO RESOLVE THE
VIOLATION SOMEBODY CAN QUIETLY --
I'M RESTORE THOSE SIGNS ARE WE
SEEING MUCH OF THAT IS A SAD AN
IMPACT IN THAT REGARD IT HAD A
HUGE IMPACT THOSE KINDS OF SMALL
VIOLATIONS ARE INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE KINDS THAT
THEIR GAMBLING THAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO SUE THEM OVER AND BY
AND LARGE THEY WERE RIGHT THOSE
ARE THE KINDS OF VIOLATIONS THAT
IT'S REALLY HARD TO PERSUADE THE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL WHO ARE VERY
BUSY TO FILE A LAWSUIT JUST TO
GET A SIGN.
DOWN BUT WITH THIS NEW AUTHORITY
WE'VE BEEN PHENOMENALLY
SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING THEM DOWN
AND THEN WE WRITE THEM A LETTER
WE KEEP AN EYE ON IT AND IF THEY
POP BACK UP AND YOU'RE RIGHT WE
HAVE RECIDIVIST SIGNS.
IS TO REAPPEAR WE JUST WRITE
ANOTHER LETTER AND SAY THAT THE
DAILY PENALTIES ARE RUNNING AND
THE SECOND TIME IT'S A KNOWING
AN INTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS WAS
EVEN EASIER.
A PUBLIC A CASE.
WHAT'S GREAT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE REPORT -- ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS WELCOME EVERYONE
WHY DON'T WE IF YOU DON'T --
MIND WE'RE GOING TO PAUSE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND TAKE CARE
OF OUR VERY BRIEF BUSINESS ON
THE VOTE ON THE CALENDAR.
BLOOM.
HERE FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
RAY YES.
REVERSE.
GREAT GOOD TO SEE YOU ALL WE ARE
OFFICIALLY ESTABLISHED NOW AND
LET'S GO TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR WE HAVE HAD A REQUEST --
TO VOTE ON ISSUES SEVEN
SEPARATELY AND DOES SO IF WE
COULD GET A MOTION ON ISSUES ONE
THROUGH SIX ABOVE THE GREAT.
BLOOM HI FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PATTERSON.
REYES.
REVERSE.
TERRIFIC A IS THERE A MOTION ON
ISSUE [inaudible]
SEVEN SECOND THAT.
AND WITH SO DO A ROLL CALL BLOOM
I FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAY YES [inaudible]
RIVAS.
SO IF THERE'S SAID NAH NO
FURTHER -- QUESTIONS ON THE
INFORMATION ITEM THEN WE WILL
MOVE ON TO ISSUE TO AN AFTER
ISSUE TO WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES.
ONE AND TWO WE ON ISSUE -- TO
FRANKLY WE CAN GET A B. C. P. ON
THIS -- BUT YOU KNOW THIS HAS TO
DO WITH AN ISSUE -- THAT'S NEAR
AND DEAR TO ALL OF US HERE WHO
CARE ABOUT -- THE THE COST OF
HOUSING WELL THE COST OF
COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE IS PRETTY
HIGH TOO AND WE KNOW THAT IT'S
EXPENSIVE AND SAN FRANCISCO.
SO YOU KNOW MY PERSONAL OPINION
ON THIS IS THAT THE INCREASE --
THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR GIVEN THE
REAL ESTATE MARKET AND AND SAN
FRANCISCO IS REASONABLE BUT AND
I'VE MADE SURE THAT THIS IS ON
THE AGENDA -- AND WE'RE KEEPING
IT OPEN BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
RECEIVE A BC PAY AND THIS IS THE
KIND OF THING THAT WE WE SHOULD
HAVE A B. C. P. ON I KNOW THAT --
THE COMMISSION'S BEEN VERY
RESPONSIVE TO LA -- AND OTHERS
SO THIS IS REALLY KIND OF JUST A
MOMENT IN TIME WHERE WE CAN SAY
THE CITIES ARE THE ORDER OF
BUSINESS YEAR.
YOU KNOW -- AND MISTRANSLATED
SIR -- LA -- IT -- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IF YOU WANT TO ADD ANY
COMMENTS THERE'S THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I'M JUST GOING
TO BRIEFLY COMMENT ON THE
RELOCATION OF OUR OUR SAN
FRANCISCO HEADQUARTERS OFFICE
THANK YOU AS YOU ALL KNOW THAT --
THIS WAS OF COURSE NOT A FIRST
CHOICE -- WE WANTED TO STAY IN
OUR OFFICE LOCATION.
WE ALL THOUGHT WE HAD INITIAL A
VERBAL AGREEMENT FROM THE
BUILDING OWNERS AT THE IN THE
LAST FISCAL YEAR.
YEAH BUT THEY CHANGE THEIR MINDS
AND AND DECIDED NOT TO IN A
RELEASE WITH THE COMMISSION AND
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY -- IN THE
BUILDING.
AND TO SAY THE LEAST THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY UNPLEASANT SURPRISE
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS TO GO
THROUGH THAT PROCESS SO WE WORK
CLOSELY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AN
APARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES. TO
FIND YOU OF OFFICE SPACE -- IT
WITHIN THE SAME GENERAL AREA AS
OUR CURRENT OFFICE LOCATION.
AND STAYING IN THE VICINITY OF
OUR CURRENT OFFICE LOCATION IS
IN SAN FRANCISCO IS REALLY
CRITICAL FOR OUR OPERATIONAL
CAPACITY OF COMMISSION STAFF --
THIS.
LOCATION ALLOWS -- EMPLOYEES TO
USE A WIDE VARIETY OF PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION TO GET TO WORK --
WE HAVE EMPLOYEES LIVE ALL OVER
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND A
100% OF OUR EMPLOYEES USE PUBLIC
TRANSIT OR WALK OR BIKE TO WORK.
IT WAS CRITICAL TO KEEP THAT
OFFICE LOCATION -- WERE.
WERE THAT WAS POSSIBLE OR RETAIN
AND ALSO RECRUITER CREATURE
STAFF IT ALSO MEETS THE STATE
GOALS IN OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
GOALS OF REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY USING PUBLIC
TRANSIT BIKING AND WALKING.
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US.
THIS LOCATION IS ALSO ESSENTIAL
FOR THE ACCESSIBILITY TO THE
PUBLIC WE SERVE FOR OUR
PARTICULAR FOR NORTH CENTRAL
DISTRICT OFFICE WHICH IS CO
LOCATED WITH OUR WITH OUR
HEADQUARTERS OFFICE.
IN THAT DISTRICT OFFICE SERVES
THE COUNTIES OF SAN MATTEO SAN
FRANCISCO MARIN AND SONOMA
COUNTIES.
AND THE CITIES WITHIN THOSE
THOSE COUNTY SO IT'S REALLY
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE THAT
ACCESSIBILITY IN OUR VIEW.
THE COMMISSION'S 200-019-2000 --
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S -- BUDGET
INCLUDES THE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION -- TO COVER MOVING AND
CONSTRUCTION COST.
IN ADDITION THE NEW OFFICE SPACE
INCLUDE SOME ADDITIONAL SQUARE
FOOTAGE THAT CAN BE SUBLEASE TO
ANOTHER STATE AGENCY AND BGS
WILL BE -- WORKING ON ON THAT
ISSUE -- IT WHEN THE NEW OFFICE
SPACES COMPLETED.
SO OUR LEASE TERM IS FOR AT TEN
YEAR LEASE WITH THE SIX YEARS
FUHRMAN FOR YOUR SOFT -- YEAH WE
ANTICIPATE WILL BE MOVING IN AND
THAT SEPTEMBER ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ALL THE CONTRACTS HAVE
BEEN SIGNED AND SO -- WITH THAT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU -- MY DAD WHO
ENCOURAGED ME TO GO TO LAW
SCHOOL -- ALWAYS USED TO SAY GET
IT IN WRITING.
LISTEN TO MY DAD -- FINANCE.
AVERAGE ELIO LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- I THINK WE
WOULD JUST ECHO THE CONCERNS
EXPRESSED BY THE CHAIR THAT NOT
GETTING OFF THE INFORMATION
THROUGH THE FORMAL BUDGETING BCP
PROCESS -- WAS A CONCERN FOR
SOMETHING OF THIS MAGNITUDE BUT
THE COMMISSION HAS BEEN REALLY
RESPONSIVE IN ANSWERING OUR
QUESTIONS OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THEM MY
USUAL THINGS ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR LEASES THAT THEY ARE --
ENTERING INTO A LEASE FOR A LOT
MORE SPACE THAN THEY NEED AND SO
WILL NEED TO FIND A
SUBCONTRACTOR -- SUBLEASE SEATED
TAKE SOME OF THAT ADDITIONAL
SPACE IN ORDER TO MAKE IT PENCIL
OUT FOR THE STATE - WHICH
PROBABLY IS NOT A DEAL THE WAY
WE WOULD WANT TO GO THINGS BUT
GIVEN THE STATE OF OF REAL
ESTATE IN COMMERCIAL REAL ESTATE
IN SAN FRANCISCO WHICH IS I
THINK BONKERS IS PROBABLY THE
TECHNICAL TERM. FOR FOR OR THE
STATE THERE WITH THEY'VE THEY'VE
SHOWN THAT THEY'VE DONE DUE
DILIGENCE AND LOOKING AT LET
OTHER -- FACILITIES AND AND
LOCATION SO I THINK IT JUST WILL
BE REALLY KEY TO GET ASSEMBLY
SEE AND THERE TO HELP OFFSET
SOME OF THE COSTS.
SO YOU'RE SAYING THE MARKET IS
BONKERS.
THAT'S A TECHNICAL TERM I GUESS
I'M GOING TO PASS THAT ON TO ARE
A REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE FROM
THE BAY AREA -- BUT IT'S BONKERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- TO DID --
FINANCE SEVENTY COMMENTS SURE
ENTERED UP THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO -- JUST PUT A BIT
BACKGROUNDS CONTACTS LAST YEAR'S
PEACE IF HE WAS -- THE THE
RESOURCES PROVIDED WERE FOR THE
COST COMMISSION TO STAY IN THE
FACILITY -- BECAUSE THERE.
BEING FORCED TO VACATE THE
FACILITY THIS FUNDING WILL --
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES NECESSARY
FOR THE NEW FACILITY -- LAST
YEAR PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE WAS
PROVIDED A KNOWLEDGE IN THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE REQUEST AND
ALLOWED FOR CURRENT YEAR
AUGMENTATION -- SO WHILE FORMAL
BUDGETING PROPOSAL WAS NOT
SUBMITTED THE INITIATION DID --
SMITH THIS PROPOSAL THROUGH AN
ISSUE SPECIFIC BASELINE
ADJUSTMENT BUT IN SAYING THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR CONCERNS AND AND
GOING FORWARD I'M GOING FORWARD
WE WILL -- HE THAT ADVICE THANK
YOU.
THAT -- A MYSTERIOUS.
AMANDA MR MULLIN.
I DON'T LIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I KEEP MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT
THE COST TO RENT.
BUT I GOT TO TELL YOU THAT --
WHEN I SEE THE FACT THAT?
THE EIGHTEEN NINETEEN ONE POINT
THREE MILLION WAS ADDED FOR THE
RENT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A LONG
TIME AGO AND NOW TO HAVE ONE
POINT.
FOUR ADDED ON TOP OF THAT.
THAT CAUSES ME GREAT CONCERN.
AND I HEAR THE EXPLANATION ABOUT
THE NEED TO BE CLOSE BY AND I
HEAR THE EXPLANATION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A COST.
OF BEING IN SAN FRANCISCO.
BUT IT BEGS THE QUESTION WHY DO
WE HAVE TO BE IN SAN FRANCISCO I
RECOGNIZE IT'S CONVENIENT. FOR
FOR FOR EMPLOYEES FOR STAFF
[inaudible]
BUT THIS IS A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
AND TO HAVE IT MORE THAN DOUBLE
FROM LAST YEAR.
I I DO HAVE.
SERIOUS CONCERNS A LOOK FURTHER
INTO IT BUT I I DO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT AND THE FACT
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE THE
THE THE THAT THERE WAS NOT IN
WRITING.
MY DAD DIDN'T TELL ME TO GET IN
WRITING BUT IN LAW SCHOOL THEY
TOLD ME YOU DON'T DO ANYTHING
UNLESS YOU HAVE IT IN WRITING.
SO IT IS OF GREAT CONCERN -- AND
I WANTED TO BE SURE TO VOICE
THEM AND MR TERRIFY BAY -- HALF
OF THE COST IS FOR TEN
IMPROVEMENT COSTS THOSE COSTS
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN INCURRED HAD
BECAUSE COMMISSION BEEN ABLE TO
STAY IN THEIR CURRENT FACILITY --
SO THEY INCREASES ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND OUT THE FULL
ONE POINT TWO BUT JUST ONE POINT
UP.
RIGHT THERE ARE NOT HAPPY.
I DON'T THINK -- THAT IN
NEGOTIATING -- THAT THE THE
COMMISSION DID ANYTHING WRONG
HERE WHEN I HAD MY LITTLE
COMMENT ABOUT -- GETTING IT IN
WRITING PRELIMINARY NEGOTIATIONS
AND DISCUSSIONS ARE ALWAYS
VERBAL AND STE THEN YOU REACH A
POINT WHERE YOU START.
TO A REDUCE THINGS TO TO WRITING
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU WERE IN
THOSE PRELIMINARY STAGES YOU
THOUGHT YOU KNEW WHAT YOU WERE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO AND THEN --
THE OWNER OF THE BUILDING OR THE
LANDLORD FOR WHATEVER REASON
DECIDED TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
RISING PCA.
A PRICES IT SAID.
IS THAT ESSENTIALLY CORRECT YES
THAT'S RIGHT AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'D ALSO NOTE BY STATUTE WERE
REQUIRED TO BE OUR HEADQUARTERS
OFFICES REQUIRED TO BE IN A
COASTAL COUNT -- SO ANY OF OUR
COASTAL AREAS.
EXTREMELY HIGH COSTS OF COURSE
SAN FRANCISCO IS BONKERS AND IT
IS ALL HIGHER ANYWHERE WITHIN
THE BAY AREA WE LOOKED AROUND
OTHER OTHER AREAS -- IN AND IT
WAS VERY COST PROHIBITIVE -- THE
BUT IT AND SO I THE KNOWLEDGE
THAT.
THE ISSUES THERE BUT YOU KNOW
PART OF MOST OF THAT IS FOR THE
YOU KNOW A GOOD PART OF THIS IS
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION AND MOVING
COSTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE REMINDER I HAD
FORGOTTEN ABOUT THE REQUIREMENT
THE THAT'S IN STATUTE -- EIGHT
AND THAT YOU'RE HAVING SAID IT
REMINDED ME I THINK I ASKED THAT
EXACT QUESTION WHEN YOU CAME
HERE -- OF FOR THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION.
MR MOE.
THEY WERE SURE WITH THROUGH THEY
WALK ME TO SAN MATEO COUNTY BUT
AS YOU SAID.
THE RENTS ARE -- MUCH BETTER ON
THE PENINSULA IT'S THERE'S BEEN
A A MAJOR RUN UP OF COURSE AND
COSTS.
AND I UNDERSTAND THE SYNERGIES
OF BEING IN SAN FRANCISCO WITH
VARIOUS OTHER AGENCIES BUT
YOU'RE NOT THE NEW LOCATION IS
NOT AT THE BAY AREA METRO CENTER
OR IS IT.
NOW BUT IT'S IN PROXIMITY I MEAN
THERE'S UP TO HOLD THEIR OF
ENTITIES BOB DID YOU PURSUE I'M
JUST CURIOUS -- DID YOU PURSUE
THE BAY AREA METRO CENTER FOR
SPACERS THAT MAXED OUT.
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
WHEN BACK TO YOU ON THAT I I
KNOW DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES
LOOKED IN SAM TAIL MORAN OAKLAND
EVEN WITH NO IN THE STATUTE --
NEEDING TO PANICLES COUNTY
OAKLAND IS NOT -- BUT WE CAN GO
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE AND JUST
CURIOUS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT -- THEN NOW WHEN WE
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES
ONE AND TWO IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO OFFER COMMENT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE OTHER OF THEM
DONE BEHALF OF US WHO LIVE NOT
AMONG CALIFORNIA AND I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS -- BY THE CALIFORNIA
COAST PROTECTION NETWORK AND
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION -- SPECIFIC
TO THE TO THE INFORMATIONAL ITEM
ON ON COASTAL ACCESS AND AND THE
ABILITY THE COMMISSION NOW TO TO
EMPLOY THIS NEW TOOL ON THAT
LEGISLATORS.
THEM. TO ENSURE THAT THE COAST --
IS MADE ACCESSIBLE TO EVERYBODY --
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS WHERE THERE
ARE LOCAL COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
HAVE TRIED TO RESTRICT ACCESS --
THE VALUE OF THIS NEW TOOL FOR
THE BECAUSE THE COMMISSION
CANNOT BE OVERSTATED -- ALTHOUGH
THE ONE THING THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT AS IT RELATES TO
THE BUDGET IS -- FROM OUR
UNDERSTANDING WE ONLY HAVE ONE
P. Y. AT THE COAST COMMISSION
CURRENTLY WHOSE WHOSE PRIMARY
JOB IS.
TO PUT MORE WORK ON COASTAL
ACCESS ISSUES AND WE THINK THAT
THAT SHOULD OBVIOUSLY BE --
INCREASE SUBSTANTIALLY
ESPECIALLY NOW AS THE COST
COMMISSION JUST ADOPTED A REALLY
STELLAR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
POLICY -- A COUPLE WEEKS AGO AT
AT THE AT THE LATEST HEARING --
WHICH WE KNOW IS GOING TO TAKE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
IMPLEMENT AS WELL -- SO WITH
THAT ONE IN A TO RAISE THOSE.
AND HIGHLIGHT THOSE ISSUES IN
PARTICULAR -- THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME.
TO COME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WE WILL MOVE ON NOW -- TO
ISSUE THREE COASTAL ADAPTATION
AND NOW YOU'LL BE JOINED BY THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
AND DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION.
THE CDC WELCOME [inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
WELL I THINK ON THIS ISSUE WE
WERE GOING TO START WITH A
PRESENTATION BY THE ALEJO TO
GIVE US KIND OF AN OVERVIEW OF
THE OF THE AREA.
pEHLERS WITH THE LA -- SERGEANTS
PASSING A HAND OUT FROM WHICH
ALL SPEAK WHICH IS ALSO ON OUR
WEBSITE -- SO STEADFAST IS TO
GIVE JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW SINCE
THIS IS KIND OF A CROSS CUTTING
ISSUE OF WHAT THE STATE'S DOING
ON COASTAL ADAPTATION ISSUES.
SO TURNING TO PAGE ONE HIM I
THINK IT'S WELL ESTABLISHED NOW
THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING UP
QUITE A BIT OF THREATS FROM THE
RISK OF RISING SEAS -- AND TIDES.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH OR WHEN
BUT WE KNOW IT'S COMING -- THE
RANGES HERE ON PAGE ONE OF THE
HAND OUT -- WILL DEPEND ON ON
WHAT HAPPENS WITH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OVER THE COMING
DECADES BUT WE SEE THAT EVEN AT
THE MINIMAL LEVELS THEY WILL
HAVE LARGE IMPACTS.
THE HAVE IMPACTS OF COURSE A
PROPERTY AND INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
ALSO TO OUR NATURAL RESOURCES
BEACH EROSION INTRUSION BREASTS
SALT WATER INTRUSION INTO
GROUNDWATER BASINS.
HABITATS AND IT'S NOT JUST THE
RISING SEAS BUT THAT EXACERBATED
BY KING TIDES AND STORM SURGES
WHICH WILL BRING -- AS WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN IN SOME RECENT
STORMS -- PERIODIC IN ADDITION
THAT WILL BE EQUALLY DAMAGING.
SO THE STATE'S GOT MULTIPLE
DEPARTMENTS WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE SEVERAL OF THEM ARE HERE
TODAY -- THEY ARE WORKING
TOGETHER WHICH IS GOOD NEWS --
BUT THEY DO EACH HAVE SOMEWHAT
OF A DIFFERENT AREA OF FOCUS THE
COASTAL COMMISSION REGULATES THE
USE OF LAND AND WATER IN THE
COASTAL ZONE WHICH GENERALLY --
GOES FROM THEM MEAN HIGH TIDE
LINE AND I THOUSAND YARDS UP
INCLUDING THROUGH LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAM -- PERMITTING WHICH I
THINK YOU'LL HEAR ABOUT -- FROM
THE DIRECTOR THE IT BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA THAT'S THE
SIMS IS GO BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION BE CDC.
WHICH REGULATES.
DEVELOPMENT IN THE BAY -- AND IS
ALSO HELPING TO COORDINATE SEA
LEVEL RISE PLANNING EFFORTS
THERE.
THE COASTAL COMMISSION GENERALLY
EXCUSE ME THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY -- GENERALLY IS
FOCUSED ON ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING
PROJECTS BOTH GIVING OUT GRANTS
GENERALLY FROM STATE BOND FUND
AS FOR PROJECTS AS WELL AS
UNDERTAKING SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS THEMSELVES.
THE OAKLAND PROTECTION COUNCIL
PLEASE A COORDINATING ROLE AND
UNDERTAKE SOME STATEWIDE EFFORTS
LIKE DATA COLLECTION AND
GUIDANCE.
AND THEN THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION IS OUR LANDLORD.
ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US FOR
PUBLIC TRUST A RESOURCES AND
SAID THE SOVEREIGN STATE LANDS
THE TIDELANDS AND SUBMERGED
LANDS.
SO TURNING TO PAGE TWO LOOKING
AT SOME OF THE FUNDING THAT THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED FOR COASTAL
ADAPTATION EFFORTS BOTH PLANNING
AND PROJECTS -- THERE HAS BEEN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
PROVIDED IN THAT THE TABLE SHOWS
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS AS WELL
AS THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
THOSE G. G. R. F..
THERE ALSO HAS BEEN SOME FUNDING
FROM BONDS AS WELL AS GENERAL
FUND I WOULD SAY IN GENERAL
THESE HAVE BEEN IN THE LOW
MILLIONS -- CUMULATIVELY SO NOT
TENS OF MILLIONS NOT MILLIONS
BUT KIND OF ON THE ON THE LOWER
END.
OF MILLIONS -- IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU TODAY THERE
ARE TWO ONGOING G. G. R. F.
APPROPRIATIONS FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND BC DC YOU CAN SEE
ON THE CHART.
I'LL LEAVE IT UP TO THOSE
DEPARTMENTS TO EXPLAIN IN DETAIL
HOW THEY'RE PROPOSING TO USE
THAT FUNDS I WILL JUST NOTE --
THERE HAS BEEN FUNDING PROVIDED
FOR THESE AGENCIES IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THOSE HAVE BEEN
ADDITIONS FROM THE LEGISLATURE
AND YEAR IF THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
PREVIOUSLY.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN PROVIDED ON A
ONE YEAR AT A TIME BASIS SO THIS
IS A DIFFERENCE IN THAT IT'S
COMING BEFORE YOU OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND FOR ON
GOING -- FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION IT'S FOR TO CONTINUE
THE WORK THEY'VE BEEN DOING FOR
BE CDC HAS THEY'LL EXPLAIN IT'S
IT'S MORE AND FOR THE IN
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT.
THERE IS NOT FUNDING AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE CHART PROPOSED FOR
THAT BECAUSE OF CONSERVANCY THAT
CLIMATE READY PROGRAM AS HAS
BEEN PROVIDED IN PRE IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS -- TURNING TO
PAGE THREE JUST SOME
CONSIDERATIONS WE WOULD
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU.
IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT MOST OF THE PLANNING AND
RESPONSE.
RESPONSIBILITIES REALLY DO LIE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL MOST OF THE
PROPERTY IS EITHER OWNED BY
PRIVATE ENTITIES ARE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
MOST OF THE DECISION MAKING OVER
LAND USE POLICIES IS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL -- SO PRIMARY FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY IS ALSO AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HOWEVER THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THE STATE SHOULD JUST WIPE
ITS HANDS AND WALK AWAY BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A HUGE STATE
INTEREST IN.
WHAT HAPPENS ALONG THE COAST AND
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS -- FROM
HEALTH AND SAFETY PERSPECTIVE --
WHAT HAPPENS TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE THE HUGE
POTENTIAL FOR ECONOMIC IMPACTS
THERE WAS A STUDY THAT CAME OUT
FROM THE?
US GEOLOGICAL SERVICE A COUPLE
OF WEEKS AGO THAT ESTIMATED A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS AT RISK IN PROPERTY
ALONG THE CALIFORNIA COAST --
AND THEN THE STATE OWNS
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL HIGHWAYS
OUR STATE BEACHES AND STATE
PARKS ALONG THE COAST.
AND WE ARE THE PUBLIC TRUST --
ENTITY THAT'S IN CHARGE OF OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND AND PUBLIC
ACCESS OF THE STATE SO -- VERY
STRONG INTEREST IN THE STATE SO
BECAUSE OF THAT WE THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS --
REPRESENT IMPORTANT MEET
IMPORTANT NEEDS -- OBVIOUSLY THE
NEEDS ARE GREATER THAN THESE
HOWEVER AND SO WELL WHAT WE
WOULD WE WOULD RECOMMEND
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
BUT ALSO.
REALLY STARTING TODAY AGAIN AND
THINK ABOUT WHAT ELSE OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES GONNA NEED FROM THE
STATE BOTH ON THE FISCAL SIDE
AND HOW CAN STATE DOLLARS BE
USED MOST EFFECTIVELY BUT ARE
THERE POLICY CHANGES AS WELL
THAT WILL HELP FACILITATE.
THE HEAVY LEFT THAT WILL -- THAT
IS FACING LOCAL COASTAL
COMMUNITIES.
SO ON THAT NOTE JUST TURNING TO
PAGE -- FOUR I THINK YOUR STAFF
HAS PUT THESE IN YOUR AGENDA AS
WELL THESE ARE SOME KEY
LEGISLATIVE QUESTIONS THAT WE
WOULD SUGGEST -- YOU FOCUS ON
NOT JUST TODAY BUT IN THE MONTHS
AND THE YEARS TO COME.
I THINK ONE OF THE REALLY KEY
ONES THIS FIRST BILL IT WHAT IS
THE STATE ROLE AS COMPARED TO
THE LOCAL ROLE AND WHERE IS THE
STATE RESPONSE AND WORK IN THE
STATE PROVIDE THE GREATEST VALUE.
AS COMPARED TO AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
HOW IS PROGRESS BEING MADE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND ARE THERE
STATE ACTIONS THAT THAT THAT CAN
HELP FACILITATE EITHER THREE
CARATS ARTHUR STICKS? TO HELP
ENSURE THAT PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE WHAT ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
USES OF STATE FUNDING ON WHAT
ARE THE SOURCES OF FUNDING AND
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL -- TOOLS
THAT MAYBE COULD BE USED AT THE
STATE LEVEL OR THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO GENERATE OR MAKE AVAILABLE
ADDITION ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF
FUNDING.
THE STATE HAS BEEN AND CAN
CONTINUE TO BE HELPFUL IN
PROVIDING DATA AND INFORMATION.
FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND TO
HELP GUIDE THEIR PLANNING AND AS
SCIENTIFIC UNDERSTANDINGS CHANGE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
STATE DATA AND INFORMATION THAT
WE'RE PROVIDING IS ALSO --
DEVELOPING ALONG WITH THAT
UNDERSTANDING.
THE STATE ASSETS THAT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR SURE -- WHAT
WHAT WE OWN AND WHAT WE ARE IN
CHARGE OF BOTH BUILDINGS BUT
AGAIN ALSO OUR STATE PARKS AND
STATE BEACHES AND ARE WE?
ON TRACK FOR OUR PLANNING AND
ADAPTING FOR THOSE TO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE ASSETS ARE ARE
PROTECTED.
AND OR ADAPTING -- AND AND WHOSE.
IN CHARGE OF THAT.
WE HAVE COST ESTIMATES VERY MUCH
THAT'S GONNA COST HAS FUNDING
BEEN IDENTIFIED.
AND THEN FINALLY THE FINAL BILL
THAT ONE OF THE MAIN TOOLS THAT
THE STATE HAS -- TO HELP AT BOTH.
COMPELLED GUIDE AND ENCOURAGE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IS THROUGH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION ADMINISTERED
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM PROCESS SO
HOW IS THAT PROCESS GOING ARE
THERE BARRIERS THAT ARE
INHIBITING.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES FROM MAKING
PROGRESS THROUGH THAT PROCESS
THAT WE CAN HOW THAT THAT YOU
ALL CAN HELP WITH -- AND AND HOW
CAN WE IT HOW CAN WE USE THAT
TOOL TO HELP -- LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS EVEN MORE
EFFECTIVELY.
SO CLOSE JUST BY SAYING THIS IS
SOMETHING OUR OFFICE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO BE MORE INVOLVED IN IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS AND
SO IF THERE ARE WAYS THAT YOU
THINK THAT WE CAN BE HELPFUL AND
AND MEETING YOUR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES AND PLEASE BE IN
DIALOGUE WITH.
US ABOUT THAT AS WELL.
THANK YOU -- DID FINANCE HAVE
ANY COMMENTS TO ADD.
OF SOME TRICKLE BACK IN MISTER
AINSWORTH -- I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU GONNA DIVIDE UP YOUR TIME
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO YOU BUT I
WONDERING -- IF AS YOU LAUNCH
INTO THIS DISCUSSION WITH -- I I
THINK WE AND THE LEGISLATURE
HERE -- PERHAPS MORE THAN THE
AVERAGE INDIVIDUAL ABOUT SEA
LEVEL RISE AND WHAT THE
STATISTICS ARE AROUND IT.
THE LA -- HAS HAS A GIVEN US A
NEAR TERM IT AT THAT TIME.
AT TWENTY THIRTY ESTIMATE OF THE
RANGE THAT WE MIGHT -- SEE THE
SEA RISE -- AND THEN A TWENTY
FIFTY ESTIMATE OF TWENTY ONE I
WONDER IF YOU COULD JUST TAKE
THAT NEAR TERM NUMBER.
AND MAKE IT REAL FOR US WHAT
DOES IT MEAN AND I MEAN GET OUT
OF EROSION OKAY I UNDERSTAND
WHAT CORROSION IS -- I
UNDERSTAND WHAT FLOODING IS BUT
GIVE US SOME CONTEXT FOR IF YOU
IF YOU WILL.
THAT'S AN YEARS AWAY AT ART ALL
OF OUR I COULD START OFF WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN -- THAT
THAT NEAR TERM -- PROJECTION OF
YOU KNOW UP TO TWO FEET WITH THE
NEXT FIFTY YEARS [inaudible]
THAT PROJECTION.
YOU KNOW DOESN'T INCLUDE ALL THE
STORM RELATED -- ASPECTS OF WHAT
HAPPENED WHAT'S DRIVING SILVERS
AND FLOODING FOR THE U. S. LIKE
WILL THE USGS STUDY JUST CAME
OUT REALLY ILLUSTRATES THIS WELL.
THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE AT RISK
SPEAK WITH.
AMPLIFIED STORMS DRIVEN BY HIS
CLIMATE CHANGE ON TOP OF THESE
OF SEAL RISE PROJECTIONS.
AND WE GET A GLIMPSE OF THAT
THROUGH OUR KING TIDES PROJECT
WE SEE -- OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE BEEN COLLECTING DATA
AND ALL SORTS OF STORIES AND
PHOTOGRAPHS IN DRAMATIC
PHOTOGRAPHS OF AREAS THAT ARE TO
THAT TODAY.
ARE INUNDATED COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING INUNDATED BY KING TIDES
ALONE IF YOU GET THAT ON TOP OF
A A STORMS -- THE HUNDRED YEAR
STORM HE CAN TALK A DEVASTATING
IMPACTS TO OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THESE ARE THINGS THAT ARE NOT
WAY OFF IN THE FUTURE -- THESE
ARE THESE ARE IT THESE ARE --
IMPACTS OUR CURRENT TODAY HAND
GOING TO THE NEAR FUTURE.
SALAS START OFF JUST WITH JUST A
QUICK GENERAL OVERVIEW OF WHAT
THE COMMISSION STEALING HERE.
AS YOU KNOW.
WE CALIFORNIA'S FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR COAST IN OCEAN
ECONOMY AND OUR AN ARC COASTAL
COMMUNITIES ARE AT SEVERE RISK
FROM CLIMATE DRIVEN SILVA RISE.
IT INVOLVES THE FLOODING
INUNDATION EROSION A BALL AND A
LOSS OF BOTH PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
PROPERTIES.
IN ONE RECENT STUDY FOUND THAT
IF WE DON'T TAKE ACTION OVER TWO
THIRDS OF OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BEACHES ALONG WILL BE
LOST IN THOSE OUR SERVER
ECONOMIC HEART AND SOUL OF OUR
OUR FOR COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
AND WITH EACH NEW STATE SEEMS TO
COME OUT IT SEEMS THE PROJECTION
SEEMS TO GET EVEN MORE GRIM AND
SEES ARE RISING FASTER.
SO WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT IT
THE COSTA COMMISSION -- AS THE
LA -- POINTED OUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION -- PER YEAR FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND TO
OUR BASE LINE BUDGET TO CONTINUE
OUR PROGRAMS GOING FORWARD AND
THESE FUNDS CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND OUR STAFF TO OVERSEE THESE
GRANTS AND THESE UPDATES TO OUR
LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAMS.
CAN OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS
WE'VE -- WE'VE AWARDED ALMOST
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO THIRTY
SEVEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OUT OF
OUR SEVENTY SIX LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ALONG THE COAST.
TO UPDATE THEIR LOCAL COASTAL
PLANS OR L. CP'S DISASSEMBLY
DRESSED THE THE RISKS.
AROUND CLIMATE CHANGE AND SILVER
RISE AND PREPARE ADAPTATION
PLANS TO ADDRESS THOSE RISK.
THESE GRANTS OF FUNDED THIRTY
THREE DRAFTER FINAL LC -- OF THE
SEAL RISING CLIMATE CHANGE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS WHICH
IS THE FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE. TWELVE DRAFT OR
FINAL ADAPTATION REPORTS WE'VE
AT THIRTY FIVE DRAFTER FINAL LCP
DOCUMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN -- IN
THE WORKS ARE COMPLETED.
WE'VE CERTIFIED ACTUALLY TH --
SEVERAL -- LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
UPDATES EXAMPLE THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND COUNTY SAN
FRANCISCO -- CITY NEWPORT BEACH
SAN CLEMENTE.
SOLANO BEACH AND SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OR SOME OF OUR RECENT --
THIS CATIONS.
AND ADDITIONAL WORK IS UNDER WAY --
INCLUDING MOST RECENT GRANT
BROWN TO OVER ROUND SIX GRANTS
OF SEVEN FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS --
TO OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS.
NOW IS YOU CAN IMAGINE THESE --
THESE ISSUES IS PLANNING ISSUES
CAN BE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS SO
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS NAVIGATE.
THE L. C. P. -- PROCESS BY
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND POLICY GUIDANCE.
AND HELP DEMYSTIFY AND THESE
COMPETING SCIENTIFIC MODELS THAT
ARE OUT THERE THE COMMISSION
ADOPTED ITS FORESEEABLE RISE
GUIDANCE DOCUMENT BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AN UPDATED
LAST YEAR TO INCLUDE THE CURRENT --
SEAL VICE PROJECTIONS COMING OUT
OF THE SCIENCE AT OPC HAD --
HAVE HAS DONE.
STAFF IS ALSO WOULD -- IS
DEVELOPING -- ADAPTATION
PLANNING GUIDANCE DOCUMENTS
FOCUSED ON RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS AND CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND THESE DOCUMENTS TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE THEY PROVIDE
PRACTICAL SAMPLE POLICY LANGUAGE
AND ADAPTATION PLANNING TOOLS TO
HELP OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BEGIN
THAT PLANNING PROCESS.
IN THROUGHOUT ALL WE ARE COOPER
WE ARE COORDINATING AND
COLLABORATING WITH OUR WONDERFUL
AGENCY PARTNERS BE DC COSTA
CONSERVANCY.
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL STATE
PARKS CALTRANS -- PIECE -- PR IN
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION --
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
COLLECTIVE EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THESE THESE ISSUES.
AN ADAPTATION IS GOING TO BE
INCREDIBLY COSTLY.
BUT IT PALES IN COMPARISON I
THINK TO THE ENDLESS EMERGENCY
RESPONSES -- BY -- BY -- BY AN
ESTIMATE OF A FOUR TO ONE GRANT
REQUESTS -- THAT WE RECEIVE CAN
TRIM THE OUT CONTINUE TO
OUTSTRIP THE FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE
WE RECEIVED ABOUT TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANT REQUEST FROM
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS.
AND WE CONTINUE TO BUILD ON THE
PROGRESS WE'RE MAKING -- OF
COURSE.
AND WE NEED TO DO THIS TO CREATE
A A SAFE AND RESILIENT
CALIFORNIA COAST FOR OUR PRESENT
FUTURE GENERATIONS -- BUT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT -- IT'S BEEN I
OPENING IT'S BEEN A LITTLE MORE.
DIFFICULT THAN WE ANTICIPATED AS
WE GET INTO THE PLANNING PROCESS
ONCE THE VULNERABILITY
ASSESSMENTS WERE DONE ARE DONE.
THE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS LOOK
AT HIM AND SAY -- GOOD LORD NOW
WHAT.
NOW I GOT TO DO THE HARD LIFTING
OF DEVELOPING POLICY SANITATION
POLICIES.
AND PEOPLE ARE YOU KNOW THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPMENT AT RISK.
PEOPLE ARE FEARFUL AND THERE'S
UNCERTAINTY INVOLVED THAT.
AND THAT LEADS TO SOMETIMES
ANGER.
AND THE ANGER SOMETIMES DIRECTED
AT US BECAUSE WE'RE DELIVERING A
MESSAGE BUT I WANT TO SHARE THIS
CASE THAT THIS COMMITTEE THAT.
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
SUPPORT OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS BECAUSE THE STRENGTH OF
THE COASTAL ACT IS FOUNDED ON
THE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN.
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THE
STATE TO CARRY OUT THE COASTAL
LACK.
SO THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN -- BACK
OR DO YOU HAVE THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER COMPACT HI
LARRY GOLD BAND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CDC LET ME GO
FIRST TO SAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE HEARING AND WE WANT TO
VERY MUCH THANK THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION FOR ITS.
CONFIDENCE IN BC DC MOVING
FORWARD ON RISING SEA LEVEL --
WHEN WE LOOK TAKE A LOOK AT THE
PROJECTIONS?
WE BASICALLY FIGURE TWO FEET OF
RISING SEA LEVELS BAKED IT.
IF NOT IT NO MATTER WHAT WE DO
NO MATTER WHAT GHG EMISSIONS
HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY
FIFTY TWO FEET IS BAKED IT.
WE TEND TO THINK MAYBE THREE
FEET IS BAKED IN BECAUSE IT
AIN'T GOING TO BE LOWER THAN TWO
FEET THAT'S FOR SURE.
AND THEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED WE BASICALLY SAID
LOOK AND THINK FOUR TO SEVEN
FEET.
MAY BE AS HIGH AS TEN ON THE
OUTSIDE BUT CERTAINLY FOUR TO
SEVEN FEET I PASSED OUT SOME
PICTURES THAT I'M NOT GOING TO
GO THROUGH THE THE PRESENTATION
I KNOW THAT.
MR MULLIN IS SEEING THEM WHICH
DEMONSTRATES THAT WHAT BC DC
DOES AS WE PERMIT PROJECTS.
IS WE HAVE RAISED WE ARE FORCED
THOSE PROJECTS TO BE ELEVATED.
SO IF YOU WALK ALONG THE SAN
FRANCISCO EMBARCADERO YOU'LL SEE
THAT AS THE NEW FERRY TERMINAL
IS BEING BUILT IT IS AT A HIGHER
ELEVATION DISTINCTLY HIGHER
ELEVATION THAN THE OLD
AGRICULTURE BUILDING NEXT TO IT.
ENDED FOR YOU IF WE HAD
PERMITTED IT NEARLY SIX MONTHS
AGO INSTEAD OF TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO IT WOULD BE HIGHER
STILL.
BE CDC DIRECTLY PERMITS THOSE
TYPES OF PROJECTS LET ME KNOW
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS SAY
AT THREE FEET BETWEEN TWO AND
THREE FEET.
IMAGINE THE BAY AREA AND IMAGINE
THAT THE BAY IS A BIG BATHTUB.
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT IS
IT'S A SHALLOW BATHTUB IT IS
SURROUNDED BY HILLS.
ON A SUNNY DAY WITH THREE FEET
OF RISING SEA LEVEL WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A STORM THE STORM
SURGE OR OR OR OR EN EL NINO.
SFO ACCESS BASICALLY IS CLOSED
OUT OF HIGHWAY ONE A ONE US ONE
NO ONE IS GOING TO BE CLOSED
AROUND SANDRA FELL INTO BRAUN.
AND CERTAINLY AROUND SAN MATTEO
AVENUE IN THAT AREA AND ALL --
HIGHWAY.
THIRTY SEVEN BASICALLY GOING TO
BE CLOSED IN VARIOUS POINTS.
WHEN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT RAIL AND
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT BART IT IS
POSSIBLE THAT A PARTS OF BARTON
MAY WELL BE CLOSED?
CERTAINLY YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
REMEMBER.
THAT A FEW YEARS AGO WHEN THERE
IS A FIVE YEAR STORM.
THE EMBARCADERO AND MONTGOMERY
MUNY STATIONS WERE CLOSED.
SO YOU CAN SORT OF ENVISION THAT
A TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
WHICH IS DEFINED AS BEING ABLE
TO GET FROM HERE TO THERE TO
THERE BY USING DIFFERENT TYPES
OF TRANSPORTATION OR DIFFERENT
ROADS IS GOING TO BE SEVERELY
AFFECTED BY SAY THREE FEET OF
RISING SEA LEVEL.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN COUNT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO HOMES AND TO
BUSINESSES.
IT IS QUITE POSSIBLE THAT AT
THREE FEET YOU MAY SEE AS MANY
AS TWENTY THOUSAND HOMES.
TAKING IN WATER AROUND THE BAY
AREA.
AND DOESN'T AND THAT DOES NOT
INCLUDE BUSINESSES SUCH AS LAND
DECKER YA WHO WERE DEL OR
SEAGATE ALL OF WHOM WILL NO
DOUBT SOMEHOW HAVE TO LOOK AT
POSSIBLY GETTING WHACKED.
THAT'S THREE FEET OF RISING SEA
LEVEL AT A STORM ADDED EL NINO
AND YOU'RE RELEASING SOME KIND
OF PATTERN THAT WE REALLY NEED
THE PLAN AGAINST AND WE NEED TO
PLAN -- FOR AND SO WHAT WE DO A.
B. C. D. C..
IS. TO LEAD THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS IN WORKING NOT ONLY ON
THEIR OWN PLANS WITH OUR HELP
AND WITH OUR DATA.
BUT ALSO WORKING TOGETHER AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE ABOUT HERE
BECAUSE THE BAY IS A NETWORK IN
SO MANY WAYS.
AND SO WHAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
IS THAT THERE'S A REGIONAL
SOLUTION FOR THIS SO THAT IF SAN
MATTEO COUNTY.
DECIDES TO BUILD SOMETHING
WHETHER IT BE A LEVY OR WHETHER
IT BE A WALL SOMEWHERE WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT IS PUT
INTO FOR EXAMPLE THE WHOLE
REGIONAL CONTEXT.
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW THAT WATER
MOVES AND SO AND WE'VE ALL
LEARNED THAT.
MOVES TO SOME EXTENT NORTH.
AND SO AS A RESULT BECAUSE WATER
REFLEX WE NEED TO HAVE A
REGIONAL SHORELINE ADAPTATION
PLAN WHICH ACTUALLY REFLECTS THE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT.
ONE ASPECT OF RESILIENCE OVER
HERE DOESN'T CAUSE FLOODING OVER
THERE.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH THE
WITH THE G. G. R. F. FUNDS IN
ADDITION TO BOLSTERING OUR STAFF
WHICH HAS BEEN DOING RISING SEA
LEVEL ON SMALL GRANTS THAT ARE
SHORT TERM.
AND NOW FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
OVER A DOZEN YEARS WILL ACTUALLY
BE SUPPORTED ALMOST FULLY BY THE
STATE.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS TO OUR
ADAPTING TO RISING TIDES PROGRAM
IS CREATING WITH CALTRANS AND
WITH THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION THE
FIRST EVER FULL SCALE
VULNERABILITY ANALYSIS?
OF THE TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
AROUND.
THE BAY.
AND IN MANY RESPECTS THAT
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK NOW
SERVES AS DE FACTO FLOOD
PROTECTION ONE OH ONE AND THE
OTHER AND THE OTHER IN AND MAJOR
ROADS LITERALLY ARE.
DE FACTO FLOOD PROTECTION BUT
WHAT BC DC IS DOING IS MORPHING
THAT KIND OF VULNERABILITY
ANALYSIS TO OUR ADAPTING RISING
TIDES PROGRAM THIS YEAR.
AND MOVING IT INTO A REGIONAL
SHORELINE ADAPTATION PLANNED
PROGRAM.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO AS WE START THAT FRAMEWORK
THIS YEAR IS TO FINISH THAT
FRAMEWORK BY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THAT DATE IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO US AND THE REASON
THAT DATES IMPORTANT.
IS BECAUSE THAT'S THE NEXT TIME
THAT A SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY
STRATEGY PLAN BAY AREA WILL
ACTUALLY COME TO THE FORE.
AND WE NEED THAT SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY TO BE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH.
OUR REGIONAL SHORELINE
ADAPTATION PLAN.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO FIT
TOGETHER THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE
LIKE THIS THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
BE PART OF EACH OTHER BUT THEY
NEED TO BE A LINE.
AND THAT'S WHY THESE FUNDS ARE
SO IMPORTANT FOR US SO WE LOOK
AT THIS REGIONALLY AND WE HAVE
AN EASIER JOB THAN JACK IN ONE
RESPECT BECAUSE OUR REGION IS
VERY MUCH SORT OF SELF CONTAINED.
BUT ALSO IF YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BAY SHORELINE AND THIS IS
HOW ALL AND THERE IS EVERYTHING
FROM HOUSES.
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES IN MANY
RESPECTS TO LARGE SCALE INDUSTRY
TO AGRICULTURE OPEN SPACE PARKS
AND THE LIKE AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ADAPTATION PLAN CAN
ACCOUNT FOR ALL OF THAT.
LET ME FINISH BY SAYING THIS IS
THE TEXAS COASTAL PLAINS.
GOES FROM BASICALLY LOUISIANA
DOWN TOWARD COPE CORPUS CHRISTI.
THERE ARE NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO LIVE RIGHT ON THE COAST IN
THAT AREA AT LEAST COMPARED TO
THE BAY AREA THERE APPEARED SOME
CERTAINLY.
AND MOST OF HOUSTON OF COURSE
YOU'RE MEMBERS INLAND ALTHOUGH
GALVESTON ISN'T.
THIS TOOK THEM A FEW YEARS TO
MAKE AND IT'S BASICALLY ABOUT
NATURE.
IMAGINE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO WITH THE REGIONAL
SHORELINE ADAPTATION PLAN THAT
DEALS WITH THE ENTIRETY OF THE
BAY SHORE LINE.
IT'S A LOT OF WORK AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS MR MALL.
JUST A COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS VERY
ISSUE AS A MATTER OF FACT I WANT
TO THANK THE DIRECTOR -- FOR
PAINTING THE PICTURE HERE AND
AND ILLUSTRATING.
A THE MAGNITUDE OF THE CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US AND
AT THE RISK OF STATING THE
OBVIOUS THE THREE POINT THREE
MILLION WHILE I WELCOME IT -- IT
THAT CAN'T BE VIEWED.
AS ANYTHING OTHER THAN A
BASELINE. FOR WHAT WE HAVE
COMING AT US -- IN TERMS OF THIS
CHALLENGE SO -- I WELCOME THE
COLLABORATION AMONG THAT THE
DIFFERENT ENTITIES AND I'D
WELCOME MY COLLEAGUES ON THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE. TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT INUNDATIONS OWN IN THE BAY
JUST TO SEE WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE.
AND AND THE LEVEL OF CHALLENGE
WHEN IT COMES TO PAY LEVEL RISE
AND ALSO -- RESILIENCY EFFORTS
AN ADAPTATION EFFORTS ON OUR
COAST WERE GETTING IT ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE COASTAL SIDE AND
THE BAYSIDE SO.
IMMENSE CHALLENGES BUT THANK YOU
FOR BEING PROACTIVE HER WELCOME
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
BEFORE WE ACTUALLY CAST A VOTE
ON THIS THING I'D.
LOVE TO SEE IT MAYBE A HIGHER
NUMBER BUT THIS IS REALLY A
MULTI YEAR GENERATIONAL KIND OF
A THING AND I I WELCOME -- THE
CHAIRS -- POINTED INTEREST -- IN
THIS ISSUE AS WELL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
WHY DON'T WE -- MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
ON THE SECOND THIRTY PUBLIC
COMMENT.
EXCITED.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SELLER GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OF THE
PROPOSED THREE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONGOING
TEACHER OUT FUNDING OUTLINED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET.
OUT ALSO JUST LIKE TO THINK THAT
LEO FOR REFERENCING THE USGS
DATA THERE IS A LA TIMES ARTICLE
THAT CAME OUT ABOUT TWO WEEKS
AGO THAT.
GIVES A PRETTY GOOD SUMMARY AND
REFERENCES ALL OF THOSE --
POINTS THAT WERE MADE TNC HAS
WORKED WITH US YES ON SOME OF
THOSE MODELS SO WE'D BE
INTERESTED OR AND ABLE TOPROVIDE STAFF WITH ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN AND FOR OTHER
THAN THE ON BEHALF OF US WHO
WILL AND I'M ON CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO BEEN ASKED TO SEE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE PROTECTION AT WORK.
I'M THREE THREE POINTS TO MAKE
WHAT ONE ON THE FUNDING WANT TO
DEFINITELY ECHO THE THE POINT
RAISED BY MY BY SOMEONE MULLIN --
ABOUT THE ADDITIONAL NEED FOR
FUNDING AND AS THIS CONVERSATION
CONTINUES ABSOLUTELY AGREE THAT
ALL THE COASTAL AGENCIES
OUTLINED IN IN THE IN THE
ANALYSIS IN THE AGENDA PLEASE ME --
ARE THE CRITICAL AGENCIES BUT
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT ONE
THIRD OF OUR COASTLINE IS
ACTUALLY OWNED AND MANAGED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE PARKS SO
I THINK.
KEEPING THEM IN CONSIDERATION AS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS BEING
CONSIDERED IS ALSO GOING TO BE A
CRITICAL PIECE TO TO ENSURING
THAT EVERYBODY'S WORKING ON THIS --
COLLECTIVELY -- THE THE SECOND
PIECE IS REALLY ABOUT VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR I KNOW
WE OFTEN CAN CAN CONSIDER THAT
JUST BY WEALTHY INDIVIDUALS ARE
THE ONES THAT LIVE ON THE COAST.
BUT WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
POCKETS ESPECIALLY IN THE SOUTH
BAY OR ALONG THAT THE CENTRAL
COAST WHERE YOU DO HAVE A VERY
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES -- THERE
ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE JUST
GIVEN THAT AND THAT AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS -- SO REALLY
WANTING TO TO HIGHLIGHT THAT AS
A AS A PRIORITY MOVING FORWARD
AND SUBSCRIPTION AND THEN
FINALLY WANT TO SAY -- REALLY
WANTED TO TO EMPHASIZE THE NEED
FOR NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE
SOLUTIONS AS WE PUT THIS
TOGETHER AND I THINK THIS
RELATES BACK TO THE THE FIRST
ITEM ON COASTAL ACCESS --
BECAUSE WE IF WE END UP
DEFAULTING OR ALLOWING CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES TO DEFAULT TO THE
HARDENING AND SEA WALLS AND
RIPRAP.
A WE KNOW THAT THAT HAS
DOWNSTREAM IMPACTS ON THE DECENT
BEACHES SO YOU END UP LOSING A
LOT OF THE SANDY BEACH AREAS AS
A RESULT -- THAT ARE WHERE AND
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WANT TO BE
WILL GO TO RETREAT AND ACCESS
THE COASTLINE -- SO WITH THAT
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY COMING.
HI JENNIFER SAVAGE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION A LETTER TO ASSOCIATE
MYSELF WITH THE REMARKS THAT WE
JUST MADE A SURFRIDER AKAS
EVERYTHING.
ALONG THOSE LINES WE AT WORK ON
THIS ISSUE EXTENSIVELY WE KNOW
THAT THE LEVEL RISES AN
EXPONENTIAL THREAT NOT ONLY TO
OUR URBAN AREAS ARE ECONOMY.
AND TO OUR STATE PARKS AND THE
RECREATIONAL USES THERE BUT ALSO
TO A VAST AMOUNT OF NATURAL
HABITAT THAT IS ONE OF OUR LAST
DEFENSES.
AROUND ABOUT THE SEA LEVEL RISE
VACANCY LEVEL RIGHT EXCUSE ME
AND THE PROBLEM AS DIRECTOR
INTEREST SAID.
ONLY GROWS MORE EXPONENTIAL WITH
EVERY REPORT THAT WE HEAR SO WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS FUNDING
AND MORE THANK YOU.
HELLO I AM YOUR OWN MONEY COME
SURELY AND I WOULD LIKE TO AT I
AM THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
BROWN GIRL SURF.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH ALFREDO O'DONNELL --
AND JENNIFER SAVAGE OF SURFRIDER --
AND ENCOURAGE YOU TO USE AN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LANDS
WHILE PLANNING OUR RESPONSES AND
ADAPTATIONS TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS MY
SUPPORT REGARDING THE PREVIOUS
AGENDA ITEM AND AND MY SUPPORT --
FOR TO SEE THAT THE COASTAL
COMMISSION HAS A MECHANISM TO
ENSURE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
COASTAL ACT AND AND TO PUT AN
END TO THE PERPETUAL SMALL
INFRACTIONS THAT SPECIFICALLY
IMPACT.
OUR COMMUNITY OF PRIMARILY GIRLS
AND WOMEN OF COLOR SURFERS AND
MANY OF WHOM ALREADY DO NOT FEEL
INCLUDED AT THE BEACH SO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR COMMENTS IF THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS -- WORLD THANK
OUR SPEAKERS -- AND TO LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU AGAIN IN
THE NEAR FUTURE -- OUR NEXT
ISSUE IS -- ISSUE.
FOR WE HAVE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION.
SPEAKING TO US ABOUT SPATIALLY
INDEXED RECORDS MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM.
GOOD MORNING.
FOR I WANT TO SAY SQUIRMS BUT I
HAVE LOTS OF FUN.
I'VE THAT -- PHILIPSSON PLEASE
WE HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO UP
APPROVED ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER LOOK AT THE I'M THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION WITH ME AS MY
COLLEAGUE PHILLIPS LATER ARE I.
T. SUPERVISOR AND OUR LEAD ON
THE SERMONS PROJECT.
OF THIS ITEM REQUEST ONE MILLION
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND. THREE PERMANENT
POSITIONS IN FISCAL YEAR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND TWENTY TO
SUPPORT THE SECOND YEAR OF THIS
A FACIALLY INDEX RECORDS
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM PROJECT KNOWN
AS SERMONS.
AND AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR ONGOING
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
WHEN COMPLETES ARMS WILL PROTECT
AND PRESERVE THE HISTORIC
RECORDS THAT DETAIL CALIFORNIANS
SOVEREIGN AND SCHOOL LAND
OWNERSHIP?
IT'LL PROVIDE A GEO REFERENCE
DIGITALLY ACCESSIBLE A PLATFORM
FOR THESE RECORDS THAT WILL
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVE THE
COMMISSION'S LEE SCENE AND
PERMITTING WORK FLOW PROCESS
SEES.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED FUNDING FOR
THE PLANNING PHASE OF THE
PROJECT.
AND IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
APPROVED FUNDING FOR ITS FIRST
YEAR IMPLEMENTATION COSTS.
THE COMMISSION IS NOW
APPROACHING THE END OF THE
SERVICE PROJECT WITH AN
ESTIMATED COMPLETION DATE OF
DECEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN AND THIS
REQUEST WILL REFUND THE FINAL
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ALONG WITH
STAFFING AND CONTRACT FUNDING
FOR ON GOING MAINTENANCE AND
OPERATIONS.
THIS REQUEST INCLUDES FUNDING
FOR SOFTWARE LICENSING INCREASE
DATA STORAGE COSTS VENDOR
CONTRACTS PLUS FUNDING FOR THREE
POSITIONS NECESSARY TO
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENT AND
MAINTAIN THE SERMONS PROJECT.
THE COMMISSION HAS WORKED
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY TO MOVE THIS ARMS
PROJECT THROUGH THE PROJECT
APPROVAL LIFECYCLE PROCESS.
AND THE PROJECT RECEIVED STAGE
FOR APPROVAL THE FINAL STEP ON
OCTOBER FIFTEENTH -- TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ARE
PHILIP CAN ADD ANY ADDITIONAL
DETAIL AS APPROPRIATE COULD YOU
JUST -- ADULT OF A LITTLE BIT OF
COLOR IF YOU WILL TO THE NOTION
OF SPATIALLY REFERENCED AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS AND A HUMAN
ELEMENT.
AND I'LL I'LL START IT OFF AND
TURN IT OVER TO FILL -- THE WHAT
MAKES THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION --
SO UNIQUE AS THE STATE'S
LANDLORD AS WAS EARLIER
REFERENCE -- REFERENCE IS THAT
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO -- STARTS
WITH THE POINT ON THE GROUND ARE
THE STATE'S OWNERSHIP AND A LOT
OF THAT -- INFORMATION ABOUT
THOSE OWNERS THAT OWNERSHIP
DATES BACK PRIOR TO STATEHOOD
AND SO WHEN WE GET REQUESTS
ABOUT WHAT THE STATE'S OWNERSHIP
IS IN CERTAIN TIED IN SOMERS
LANDS ARE NAVIGABLE WATERWAYS.
WERE ON A DAILY BASIS ACCESSING
HISTORICAL RECORDS THAT DATE
BACK PRIOR TO EIGHTEEN FIFTY AND
THEN MOVING THROUGH TIME -- AS
THAT LAND OWNERSHIP OF ALL TO
AND APPLYING BOTH THE FAX TO THE
GROUND AS WELL AS THE LAN HOW
THAT -- OWNERSHIP HAS BEEN --
LEGALLY INTERPRETED OVER THE
YEARS.
AND THE WAY WE DO THAT IN HOUSE
IS MANUALLY WE HAVE A MANUAL
TITLE PLANT -- THAT TO DETERMINE
THE EXTENT OF THE STATE'S
OWNERSHIP AND WHAT THIS PROJECT
DOES IS IT BRINGS US IN -- TO
THAT THAT TECHNOLOGICAL STAGE
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY DO THE
MAJORITY OF THAT RESEARCH AND
ANALYTICAL WORK -- USING -- GIS
AND THE SYSTEM -- AT TO HELP --
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
MORE EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
AND THEN -- ALSO AT THE END PART
OF THIS PROJECT IS TO TURN THIS
INTO A PUBLIC FACE SEEN -- WEB
APPLICATION SO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN ACCESS THEIR HISTORICAL
RECORDS MORE DIRECTLY.
PHIL DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING ELSE
TO ADD TO THAT -- I WOULD ONLY
ADD THAT AND WE USE THOSE MAPS
AND DOCUMENTS AS WORK PRODUCT
AND THAT'S TAKEN ITS TOLL ON
THOSE RECORDS THAT ARE KIND OF A
REPLACEABLE AND SO.
MAKING THEM DIGITAL IS YOU KNOW
THE WAY TO PRESERVE THEM FOR YOU
KNOW OUR OUR FUTURE NEEDS AND
AND USES -- ANOTHER ANOTHER
PIECE I WOULD ADD IS THE SYSTEM
IS ARCHITECTED IN SUCH A WAY
WHERE.
WE'LL BE ABLE TO HAVE A BOWL
STAFF AND THE PUBLIC ACCESS IT
FROM A CENTRAL SOURCE -- AND SO
THAT THAT'S GIVING US A LOT OF
EFFICIENCY -- WITH WITH THE
SYSTEM.
THANK YOU A MISTER FONG WHICH OF
COURSE.
OF I APPRECIATE THAT INFORMATION
I WAS WONDERING IF WE COULD
DELVE A LITTLE DEEPER AB MATCH
AS SHE GENTLY CURIOUS IN TERMS
OF WHEN YOU PUT THE PROJECT
TOGETHER DO YOU DID YOU USE.
OFF THE SHELF TECHNOLOGY OR DID
YOU -- DEVELOP YOUR OWN PLATFORM --
BECAUSE THAT IT SEEMS LIKE THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WE WOULD LIKE THE PUBLIC TO BE
ABLE TO INTERFACE WITH A LOT
AGENCIES IN THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS.
RELATIVELY ON TIME AND UNDER
BUDGET IS ACTUALLY VERY
SURPRISING AND PLEASANTLY
SURPRISED AS WELL.
YES SO -- WE'RE LEVERAGING --
MAINSTREAM CLOUD SOLUTIONS FOR
THIS WERE WERE PRIMARILY
LEVERAGING THE MICROSOFT CLOUD --
FOR THIS IMPLEMENTATION -- WHAT
THAT DOES IS THAT GIVES US A
MUCH QUICKER DEVELOPMENT TIME --
YOU KNOW WE'RE WE'RE NOT DOING
ANY CODING WITH THIS PROJECT
WE'RE GETTING A LOT
CONFIGURATION -- USING YOU KNOW
PRE BUILT APPLICATIONS AND
SOLUTIONS AND INTEGRATING THOSE
SOLUTIONS TOGETHER AND SO THAT'S
GIVING US A MUCH MORE.
RAPID IMPLEMENTATION TIME FOR
HIM DID YOU FEEL THAT WAS.
RELATIVELY EASIER BECAUSE YOU'RE
USING OFF THE SHELF -- THINGS
THAT WERE -- A READILY AVAILABLE
RIGHT YEAH IT DAY BASICALLY TO
YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE INITIAL
LEAD TIMES AND AND STANDING UP
THAT THE TYPICAL TECHNOLOGY
INFRASTRUCTURE -- YOU KNOW
BASICALLY WHERE WERE ABLE TO
SKIP RIGHT OVER THAT AND GET
RIGHT INTO BUILDING BUILDING THE
SOLUTION CORRECT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
IT'S GREAT -- BUT THERE'S NO
FURTHER QUESTIONS SIR PUBLIC
COMMENT.
NO PUBLIC COMMENT SO -- WE HAVE
A RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ITEM TO
APPROVE AS BUDGET IT IS OUR
MOTION. TO HEAR SECOND.
MOTION A SECOND.
BLOOM I FONG.
GARCIA MULLIN.
PERCENT.
RADIUS REVERSE [inaudible]
YES I THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
SHOULD THE REPORT KEEP UP THE
GOOD WORK AND WILL MOVE ON TO
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
WE HAVE [inaudible] FIVE FIVE
ITEMS TO COVER WILL TAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER WE'VE HEARD THE
OTHER REPORT ON ALL OF THESE
ITEMS AND TO WALK.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU HERE IF I MIGHT
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OPENING
REMARKS OF COURSE ANY PLACE FROM
THANK YOU FIRST OF ALL FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY AND FOR
YOUR THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION --
FOR THE BUDGET I'M LEAST MARKET
ON THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THIS YEAR
MAKES VERY STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS
IN STATE PARKS WHILE MAINTAINING
THE COMMITMENT TO IMPLEMENT THE
SIGNATURE INITIATIVES THAT HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE LEGISLATURE
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS. ONE
OF THE MOST NOTABLE THAT I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT IS LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND
PROVIDED THE ORGANIZATION --
THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
NEW POSITIONS -- TO HELP
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS THROUGH THAT WILL BE ABLE
TO BETTER -- PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S RESOURCES AUGMENT
OUR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS ALSO ON
FIXING OUR PARKS BY AUGMENTING
OUR MAINTENANCE EFFORTS AND THAT
INCLUDES A REST DISABILITIES
VISITOR CENTERS ROADS TRAILS ALL
OF THOSE THINGS WATER SYSTEMS
THAT COMES.
COME TO MIND THAT ARE IMPORTANT
IN ORDER FOR US TO SERVE THE
VISITORS -- WE LAUNCHED A
RECRUITMENT CAMPAIGN CALLED LIFT
THE PARKS LIFE.
AND WE ARE TRYING TO RETHINK AND
RETOOL HOW WE RECRUIT AND MAKING
SURE THAT WERE BY PARTICIPATING
IN A VAST NETWORK OF PARTNERS.
AND REACHING -- FAR MORE
COMMUNITIES THAN WE EVER HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT TO REACHING --
TALENTED INDIVIDUALS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE THAT WILL COME AND
JOIN US TO SERVE THE PUBLIC.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER FOUR
YEAR PERIOD AND ONE TIME FUNDS
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
THIS BUILDS UPON THE ROUGHLY ONE
HUNDRED POSITIONS THAT YOU
PROVIDED US LAST YEAR FOR
ONGOING MAINTENANCE AND IT ALSO
BUILDS UPON THE ROUGHLY EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS.
IN ONE TIME FUNDING THAT YOU
PROVIDED FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE -- SO HOW ARE WE
GOING TO PRIORITIZE THOSE
PROJECTS WHEN -- WE'VE GOT A
ROUGHLY ONE BILLION DOLLARS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BACKLOG --
WE WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
FIELD WE WORK ON THAT AT SOME
POINTS WITH SOME OTHER PARTNERS
AND OPERATORS AND WE HELP
DETERMINE A PRIOR TO A
PRIORITIZED LIST.
ON TYPICALLY WE'VE WE LOOK AT
THINGS LIKE HEALTH AND SAFETY
WATER SYSTEMS ANTIQUATED ROOFS
ROADS -- WE ARE WORKING RIGHT
NOW ON DEVELOPING A LIST THAT
WILL BE PRESENTING TO YOU
SHORTLY SHARING WITH YOU AND I
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE THINGS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU SEEN OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS -- THAT
WE'VE TARGETED.
LASTLY -- WE CONTINUED FOCUS ON
THE SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION.
SIXTY EIGHT PROPOSITION SIXTY
EIGHT INCLUDE SOME OF THE
STRONGEST LANGUAGE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE ON MAKING SURE THAT
THESE FUNDS ARE BEING USED IN
FOCUS FOR PART POOR COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S
ACCESS -- TO PARKS IN THE
ECOSYSTEM OF PARKS NOT JUST
STATE PARKS BUT LOCAL PARKS ALL
LANDS IS ACTUALLY CRITICAL --
FOR THRIVING NEIGHBORHOODS
ACROSS THE STATE.
WHEN WE LAUNCHED OUR EFFORTS WE
BEGAN THROUGH A PUBLIC
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS WORKING WITH
THE PUBLIC AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AS WE DEVELOP -- POLICIES AND
GUIDELINES THAT WILL HELP
DETERMINE HOW THESE FUNDS WILL
BE DISTRIBUTED.
ON WE ARE WRAPPING UP THAT
PROCESS WERE VERY PLEASED BY THE
OUT THE THE ATTENDANCE AND THE
ENGAGEMENT OUT AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED WITH
THAT -- IN CLOSING I GUESS I
WOULD SHARE THAT ARE INVESTMENT
PARKS IS REALLY HAVE AN
EXPRESSION OF OUR CALIFORNIA
VALUES WE'VE YOU CALIFORNIA
PARKS IS REALLY A STATEMENT OF
WHAT WE DEEM -- TO BE NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEARTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT IT'S OUR
COMMITMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE IT
THINGS THINGS ARE WORTHY OF
PROTECTION.
AND SO WITH THAT -- I'LL OPEN UP
TO ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS OR
I CAN DIVE RIGHT INTO THE NEXT
ISSUE.
HI I'M NOT SEEN ENHANCE GO UP --
TO MR FONG.
I'M I APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING AND AND THE THE PUBLIC
INPUT YOUR GATHERING I WOULD
WANT TO ASK JUST BECAUSE THE OF
THE HEADLINE TODAY ABOUT THE THE
CHALLENGES WITH THIS GUY OUT --
AND READING THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS CAN YOU SHED SOME LIGHT
IN TERMS OF YOUR INTERACTION I I
DON'T I DON'T I BELIEVE YOU'RE
KIND OF TAKING AND WHAT YOU HAVE
TO AND DOOR WITH THIS GAS I WAS
ONE OF YOU JUST.
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE JUST
YOUR INTERACTIONS WITH
IMPLEMENTING THIS GALLON AND IN
JUST ANY INSIGHT YOU CAN PROVIDE
US SO MAYBE I CAN SUGGEST THAT
YOU DIVE RIGHT INTO ISSUE FIVE
OH I'M SORRY IT'S COVERED IN
FIVE AND ANSWER THE QUESTION IN
THE CONTEXT OF OF OTHER MARCHING
AGAINST.
ON THAT ISSUE THAT ALL RIGHT
APPRECIATE THAT YEAH SORRY FOR A
JOB THAT ORDER MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HAPPEN TO BE HAPPY TO DO THAT SO
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE ON PAGE
SEVENTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA IS THAT
VERY ISSUE -- SO THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET REQUEST ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND ON GOING
FOR TWELVE POSITIONS. TO ADDRESS
SPECIALIZED ACCOUNTING WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE MIGRATION -- TO
THE STATE WIDE FISCAL SYSTEM WE
ACTUALLY -- STARTED THIS
MIGRATION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN IT'S BEEN NO EASY FEAT --
BUT WE ARE ONE OF THE LARGEST
ECONOMIES IN THE WORLD I THINK
MUCH OF KIND OF WHAT WITH THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE WERE FACING
SOME OF THEM I WOULD SAY WERE IN
THE BUCKET OF THINGS THAT WE
ANTICIPATED.
AND SOME OF THE THINGS I WOULD
SAY YOU'RE PROBABLY LESSONS
LEARNED WE'RE FAIRLY UNIQUE
DEPARTMENT LAW I KNOW EVERY
DEPARTMENT THINKS THAT ABOUT
THEMSELVES WHAT MAKES A SOMEWHAT
UNIQUELY CHALLENGED AS THE
VOLUME OF FUNDS THAT WE HAVE.
WE ALSO COLLECT REVENUES -- WE
ALSO MAKE A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
PAYMENTS TO VENDORS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE WE'RE NOT LOCATED IN
LARGE URBAN AREAS WITH MANY MANY
MANY VENDORS.
BUT WERE OFTEN REMOTELY LOCATED
WHERE THE NUMBER OF VENDORS ARE
SOMEWHAT LIMITED SO BEING ABLE
TO MAKE TIMELY PAYMENT TO THE
VENDORS ARE REALLY KEY.
I'M GONNA SHARE -- SOME
STATISTICS WITH YOU -- THAT KIND
OF MAKE US A LITTLE MORE
UNIQUELY POSITIONED RELATIVE TO
OTHER DEPARTMENTS -- I WOULD SAY.
WELL WELL FIRST I SHOULD SAME
YOU KNOW WHEN WE DID THE
MIGRATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN I THINK WE WE TREAT
ALL OF THE WORKLOAD AS IT WAS AS
IF IT WAS GONNA BE ONE TIME IN
NATURE BECAUSE IT WAS REALLY
PREMATURE. TO MAKE AN ASSESSMENT
IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH OF THIS
WOULD BE ON GOING SO WE
RESPONDED.
IN A ONE TIME NATURE WE HIRED
TEMPORARY STAFF WE ASKED OUR
STAFF TO KIND OF RISE TO THE
OCCASION AND DO OVERTIME SORRY
ACCOUNTING AND BUSINESS SERVICES
STAFF DID OVER TEN THOUSAND
HOURS OF OVERTIME.
TYPICALLY PEOPLE IN THOSE
POSITIONS UNDERSTANDS THAT WE
EXPECT OVER TIME BUT THAT
THERE'S A SEASONALITY TO IT AND
WE'VE NOT SEEN A SEASONALITY
THAT THIS IS A CONTINUE TO STAND
LEVEL OF OVERTIME.
WE ALSO -- TREATED THIS IS AN
ALL HANDS ON DECK EFFORT -- WE
HAD FOLKS OUT IN THE FIELD AND
OUT IN OUR TWENTY ONE DISTRICTS --
INCLUDING PEOPLE IN HEADQUARTERS --
SHARING IN RE DIRECTING STAFF TO
ALSO HELP AUGMENT THIS EFFORT.
SO I THINK WELL THAT WAS A
REALLY SMART WAY TO APPROACH
THIS AND IT WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN THE NEAR TERM WE STILL HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO OVERCOME KIND
OF THE THEIR GROWING BACKLOG OF
WORK LET THAT WE HAVE.
WE ALSO NOT ONLY DO THE BUDGET
FOR OUR OWN ORGANIZATION THE
DEPARTMENT PARKS AND RECREATION
BUT WE ALSO PRODUCE THE BUDGET
AND THE FISCAL ON INFORMATION.
FOR THREE SMALLER CONSERVANCY'S --
THE BALDWIN HILLS CONSERVANCY
CONSERVANCY IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY MOUNTAINS SO THAT ALSO --
PROVIDES A LAYER OF COMPLEXITY
SO IN TERMS OF NO WE ALSO
CREATED SOME INTERNAL DATABASES
THAT HELP TO KIND OF AUTOMATE
SOME THINGS.
SO IT'S A COMBINATION IN TERMS
OF THE ON GOING RECORD ITS
COMBINATION OF TRACKING SOME
THINGS THAT IN THE PAST WE
HADN'T TRACK BECAUSE WE'RE
TRYING TO MEET A HIGHER STANDARD
OF ACCOUNTING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA NOW.
AND A HIGHER LEVEL OF
TRANSPARENCY BUT THEN THE OTHER
THING I WOULD SAY THAT THERE
WERE SOME ACTIVITIES THAT WE MAY
HAVE DONE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS OR
QUARTERLY BASIS OR A MONTHLY
BASIS.
THAT NOW WE'RE HAVING TO DO ON A
DAILY BASIS WEEKLY BASIS AND
WE'RE HAVING TO DO THE MORE
FREQUENTLY -- SO I THINK IN THE
LONG TERM I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT
IT'S A GOOD THING FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT YOU'RE KIND OF
CATCHING US RIGHT IN NOT RIGHT
IN THAT KIND OF MOMENT IN TIME
WHERE WERE FIGURING THIS OUT.
THE REQUEST THAT WE HAVE BEFORE
YOU TODAY I MUST SAY WE DID NOT
PRESENT THIS TO YOU LIGHTLY --
OR APPROACH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE LIGHTLY -- THIS REQUEST
IS INTENDED TO BE A NOT A FACT
OF SOME ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT A ONE
TIME WORKLOAD DECLINING.
AND THEN WITH THE NOT A FACT OF
WHAT WHAT WE ANTICIPATE WILL BE
ON GOING WORKLOAD.
IF I MAY FOLLOW UP -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE INFORMATION
ARE YOU PROVIDING THAT AS IS
FISCALE OPEN TO YOUR SUGGESTIONS
IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING THESE
CHALLENGES.
AS AS THE BEING UNIQUE AGENCY AB
I I DO APPRECIATE THAT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT -- I THINK THE
CHALLENGE FOR US IS THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY YOU'RE NOT UNIQUE
IN THE IN THE AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH FISCAL WITH OTHER
AGENCIES IN THE AND THEIR
DIFFICULTIES AS WELL SO ARE YOU
ARE YOU.
IS FISCAL ASKING YOU FOR YOUR
INPUT AND HOW TO IMPROVE AND ARE
THEY LISTENING -- YES I THINK
BEFORE WE ACTUALLY CONDUCTED THE
MIGRATION THERE WAS A LOT OF
STAFF COLLABORATION -- I CAN SAY
EVEN MYSELF I'M NOT A SHY
DIRECTOR AND I COME FROM A BIT
OF IT IN MINISTRY OF IN FISCAL
BACKGROUND SO I WASN'T SIGNED
JUMPING ON MYSELF.
AND ATTENDING SOME OF THE
MEETINGS WE ACTUALLY KIND OF HAD
ON GOING ON MEETINGS WERE FISCAL
STAFF FOR EMBEDDED WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS THAT I CAN
TELL IS EVERYONE'S WORKING WELL
TOGETHER IS THAT WHEN I STEP IN
AND ATTEND SOME OF THOSE
MEETINGS EVERYBODY KNOWS EACH
OTHER HOW MANY KIDS EACH OTHER
HAS.
YOU CAN TELL THAT THEY'VE BEEN
SPENDING A LOT OF TIME --
INITIALLY WHEN WE WHEN WE
CONDUCTED THE MIGRATION I ALSO
WAS HAVING.
YOU KNOW ONE ON ONE
CONVERSATIONS WITH US SOME OF
THE LEADERSHIP TEAM THERE AT THE
FIFTH CAL DEPARTMENT SO -- I
THINK THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY
ENGAGED I FEEL LIKE -- THEY'VE
BEEN PRETTY RESPONSIVE -- TO
REALLY KIND OF FLAGGING AND
TRYING TO WORK OUT SOME OF THE
WRINKLES AND SO THIS IS A RESULT
OF YOU KNOW THIS IS THE RESULT
OF YEARS OF COLLABORATION
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM --
THIS IS NOT A STARTING POINT FOR
CONVERSATION WITH THEM.
OKAY I PUSHED IN AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE AYE AYE.
AYE AYE AYE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT IT TO HEAR IT AS AS
KIM I'M TRYING TO IT'S
INTERESTING TO JUXTAPOSE.
THE LAST IT PROJECT THAT WE HAD
THAT WAS HEARD FROM -- THEY USE
OFF THE SHELF TECHNOLOGY AND IS
NOW UNDER BUDGET AND ON TIME AND
FISCALE AND THEIR CHALLENGES THE
FACT THAT NOW YOU YOU'VE HAD TO
CREATE YOUR OWN INTERNAL
DATABASES WHICH I HOPE INTERFACE.
WITH NOT ONLY VIZQUEL BUT WITH
ALL THE OTHER AGENCIES THAT
YOU'RE INTERACTING WITH AS WE
HEARD WITH THE PREVIOUS
TESTIMNY OF STATE PARKS IN THE
ROLE WITH THE COST OF COMMISSION
AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
I HOPE THAT THERE'S SOME SYNERGY
THERE AND MY FEAR IS THAT.
WITH ALL THE CHALLENGES WITH THE
ID PROJECTS IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA THAT WE DON'T MAKE
THOSE SAME MISTAKES I THAT YOU
HAVE TO IN DOOR AND BE THE PICK
THEM UP SO I APPRECIATE THE
INFORMATION THANK YOU MUCH
INSTRUMENT.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
ON ISSUE -- FIVE DO WE HAVE THE
LA OVER FINANCE COMMENTS AND
LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE SIX THE
INDIAN HERITAGE.
CENTER STAFFING.
THE TERM THIS CITING PROJECT ON
THIS ISSUE WE'RE REQUESTING FOR
NINE TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND FOR
THREE POSITIONS TO PATROL
MAINTAINED.
AND DEVELOP THE CALIFORNIA
INDIAN HERITAGE CENTER SO JUST --
BY WAY OF SOME CONTEXT YOU MAY
RECALL THAT WE WERE BEFORE YOU
LAST YEAR AND YOU APPROVED -- A
PROPOSAL TO BUILD A NEW
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HERITAGE
CULTURAL CENTRE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- IT'S IT'S AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
STATE IT'S GOING TO REPLACE A
VERY ANTIQUATED -- INDIAN MUSEUM
THAT WE HAVE CO LOCATED AT
SUTTER'S FORT WHICH YOU CAN
IMAGINE GIVEN THE COMPLICATED
HISTORY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT'S BEEN --
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC THEY
WERE VERY PLEASED WITH THIS
WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH --
THE GOVERNOR'S TRIBAL ADVISER
CRISTINA SNYDER -- SHE'S BEEN IN
VERY CLOSE CONTACT WITH THE
TRIBAL COMMUNITY -- OUR HOPE IS
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE -- TO TAKE
THE RESOURCES THAT YOU PROVIDED
US LAST YEAR TO ALSO EXPAND THAT
THROUGH PHILANTHROPIC SUPPORTS --
WHEN WE LAST SPOKE TO YOU WE
STATED THAT OUR INTENTION WAS TO
SITE THIS?
SITE THAT WAS LOCATED BUT WAS
STOPPED BY A TIE A TASK FORCE ON
THAT WAS ORIGINALLY STAB US
RELATIVE TO THIS PROJECT THAT
SHOWS A LOCATION AT THE
CONFLUENCE OF THE TWO RIVERS.
IN THE CITY OF LOS SACRAMENTO AT
THE TIME THAT WE SPOKE TO YOU
LAST YEAR WE HAD NOT OF FINALIZE
THE SECURING THE SECURING OF
THAT PROPERTY WE'RE VERY PLEASED
TO SAY THAT WE WORKED CLOSELY
WITH THE CITY OF AUSTIN WAS
SACRAMENTO.
AND WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO SECURE
THAT PROPERTY ON AT THE TIME
THAT WE PRESENTED TO YOU LAST
YEAR WE KNEW THAT WE MIGHT NEED
SOME INITIAL RESOURCES BUT IT
WAS OUR INTENT AND WE DID --
DISCUSSED WITH THE CITY OF THE
WEST SACRAMENTO POSSIBLY SOME
SORT OF PARTNERSHIP WHERE THEY
COULD ADDRESS OF THIS INITIAL
WORKLOAD WE WERE NOT SUCCESSFUL
IN THAT SO WE HEAR BEFORE YOU.
THESE RESOURCES ALLOW US TO BE A
GOOD NEIGHBOR IF YOU GO TO THE
SITE IT'S NOT A REMOTE LOCATION
IT'S EMBEDDED RIGHT THERE WITHIN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY [inaudible]
GREAT -- ISSUE.
SEVEN ISSUE SEVEN AS THE
CALIFORNIA MUSEUM IF YOU'VE NOT
BEEN TO THE CALIFORNIA MUSEUM
IT'S A MUSEUM LOCATED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
IT WAS BUILT WITH THE INTENTION
TO SHOWCASE A LOT OF THE
COLLECTION -- OF THE STATE
ARCHIVIST WE ALSO PARTNER VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM TO SHOWCASE
MANY OF THE COLLECTIONS THAT ARE
UNDER OUR STEWARDSHIP ON HERE --
UNDER CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS --
IT'S NOT.
GENERALLY HOW THIS WOULD WORK IS
THIS IS A MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND AND OUR DEPARTMENT
WOULD REALLY SERVE JUST AS A
PASS THROUGH IN THIS MONEY WOULD
GO FROM US TO THE CALIFORNIA
MUSEUM CONSISTENT WITH.
HOW WE'VE APPROACH SIMILAR
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THIS
ORGANIZATION IN THE PAST THE
FUNDING THAT'S BEING REQUESTED?
IS FOR INITIALLY TO CELEBRATE
THE ONE HUNDRED YEARS OF THE
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT AND
GENDER JUSTICE AND SO THAT WOULD
BE A CENTENNIAL EXHIBIT BUT
THEY'RE PLANNING FOR THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN -- FOR
THEY THEN A PLAN TO USE IT FOR
PERMANENT EXHIBIT SHOWCASING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS
SIR ISSUE EIGHT PLEASE.
ISSUE WAIT THE REPLACEMENT OF
SPECIALIZED EMERGENCY MOBILE
EQUIPMENT.
SO UNDER THIS PROPOSAL OR
PROVIDE ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
AND ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION OVER
A TWO YEAR PERIOD.
AND DURING THAT TWO YEAR PERIOD
THIS FUNDING WOULD ALLOW US TO
PROCURE FOR A SURF RESCUE
VESSELS.
A FIXED WING AIRCRAFT FOR ANSWER
BREAK GO AND ALSO A FIRE
FIGHTING APPARATUS WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY A FIRE TRUCK FOR
HEARST CASTLE SO I CAN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
WHAT THIS MEANS -- I THINK THAT
THERE'S A HEIGHTENED SENSE OF
AWARENESS PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
OF THE RECENT DISASTERS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS PLAYS IN
THE IN THE OVERALL SAFETY NET IN
COMMUNITIES -- AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF OF THIS TYPE OF
EQUIPMENT -- THE WATER RESCUE
VESSELS ARE NOT JUST YOUR
TYPICAL VOTES THEY HAVE DEEP
DEEP V. HOLD VESSELS SO THAT
THEY CAN GO INTO.
SURF -- AT WITHOUT CAPSIZING
WHERE TYPICAL BOATS COULD NOT GO
WE DO -- WITH THE FOUR VESSELS
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE WE DO
OVER A THOUSAND RESCUES EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
WE'VE GOT A PREMIER LIFEGUARD
PROGRAM THAT'S REALLY KNOWN
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD -- AS
TRAINING AMAZING LIFEGUARDS IT
ALSO HAS TWO ENGINES THAT ALLOWS
IT TO PIVOT THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DEGREES OF THESE ARE VERY
UNIQUE.
ON THESE VESSELS TO SAY THAT
THEIR OLD IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT --
I WOULD HIGHLIGHT THAT OUR
OLDEST VESSEL IS THIRTY TWO
YEARS OLD -- SO I WAS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AT THE TIME THAT WE MADE
THAT PURCHASE WITH THE IN THE
OTHER VESSELS THIRTY YEARS OLD
AND TWENTY ONE YEARS OLD -- THE
FIXED WING AIRPLANE WE HAVE AN
AIRPLANE THAT'S A THIRTY THREE
YEARS OLD -- OUT AN ANSWER BREAK
OUT INTO A BREAK -- IS THE
LARGEST STATE PARK IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE
SALTON SEA IN AN AREA AKA TEAL
WELLS AND WERE AN IMPORTANT PART
OF THE SAFETY NETWORK AND IT
ALLOWS US TO PATROL.
VAST AREAS IN -- SOME PRETTY
HARSH -- CIRCUMSTANCES AND BOATS
ARE REQUEST.
THANK YOU I AM OUR LAST ISSUE IS.
NINE ISSUE NUMBER -- NINE THIS
IS A LIST OF OUR VARIOUS CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROJECTS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE PROJECT FOR
CENTER TO YOU TODAY.
ARE A CONTINUATION OF PROJECTS
THAT WE HAVE FOR THAT WE
PRESENTED TO YOU IN THE IN THE
PAST SO THEIR FUTURE -- UP MOST
OF THEM ARE FUTURE PHASES --
THAT WE AT FIVE THREE AM PRIOR
DISCUSSIONS [inaudible]
GREAT.
WHY DON'T WE ASK FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ISSUES FIVE SIX SEVEN
EIGHT AND?
NINE THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS HOLLY
MARTINEZ AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET.
AT THE FOUNDATION WE ARE
PRIORITIZING ADVOCACY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO OUR TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
STATE PARK SYSTEM. TO ENSURE
THEY REMAIN PROTECTED AND
PRESERVED AND ALSO ENSURE THAT
THEIR ADEQUATELY IN SUSTAINABLY
FUNDED -- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
THIS PROPOSAL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
MANY OF THE REQUEST FOR FUNDING
WITHIN IT A LINE WITH THESE --
PRIORITIES SPECIFICALLY AS IT
RELATES TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO OUR
STATE PARKS AS WELL AS ENHANCED
VISITOR EXPERIENCES TO THESE
PLACES.
ARE THAT'S DEMONSTRATED THROUGH
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AT
INVESTMENT OF FUNDS AS WELL AS
THE FORT ROSS CULTURAL TRAIL
THAT WILL BE ESTABLISHED THAT
WILL NOT ONLY.
TELL THE STORY OF THESE LANDS
BUT ALSO IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL
ACTIVITIES FOR STUDENTS -- AND
FINALLY MOST NOTABLY THE
CONSTRUCTION OF FIFTEEN CABINS
THAT TRULY DO -- INCREASE LOW
COST COASTAL COMBINATIONS TELLS
CALIFORNIANS WHO WE KNOW WOULD
OTHERWISE NOT BE ABLE TO ENJOY
THESE THESE EXPERIENCES.
OF FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE PROPOSAL ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
A GOOD MORNING AGAIN WAS A TERM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
FEDERAL NON BEHALF OF US SOON --
COALITION KNOWN AS A PARKS NOW
COALITION -- THEY'RE ACTUALLY
HERE TODAY IN SACRAMENTO FROM
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE A
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS HERE.
SO WANTED TO TO ASK PERMISSION
FROM THE CHAIR OF POSSIBLE TO TO
BE ABLE -- TO MAKE COMMENTS ON
I'M NOT JUST THE PARTS RELATED
ITEMS IN PROP -- SIXTY EIGHT BUT
SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN IN THE LETTER
THAT WAS TO SHARE WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- GIVEN THAT YOU KNOW
THE MOST THE PROJECTS STATE WAS
HANDLED IN IN PREVIOUS --
HEARING.
THE ONE THING I WOULD SAY THOUGH
IS THAT WE'VE BEEN VERY -- VERY
ENCOURAGED AND VERY HAPPY TO SEE
THE RESPONSIVENESS FROM STATE
PARKS -- UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE DIRECTOR AND AND ACTUALLY
HALF OF THE GROUPS ARE ARE
TALKING NOW IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE
ROOM WITH -- FOLKS ARE
IMPLEMENTING -- FROM THE GALS
THE A SEPARATE THE OFFICE OF
GRANTS AND LOCAL ASSISTANCE --
FOCUSED ON THE STATE WHAT PART
PROGRAM WHICH IS LIKE HOW
COMMITTED THEY ARE THEY'RE
WILLING TO MEET WITH US NOW --
BUT WE REALLY WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
DOING GREAT WORK AS IT RELATES
TO THE COMMUNITY ACCESS ISSUE --
AND I WILL LEAVE IT AT THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE OF THE FOLKS
HERE.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING TO THE COMMITTEE --
MY NAME IS D. ON WEST.
HI I'M WITH THE OUTDOOR OUR
REGION IN THE PARKS NOW
COALITION -- MY SPECIFIC
POSITION WITHOUT OUR OUR REACH
IS THE YOUTH PROGRAMS AND
OUTDOOR VOICES COORDINATOR WHERE
MY JOB IS TO CONNECT -- SAN
DIEGO USED TO THE OUTDOORS SO I
GREW UP IN THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
WHERE THERE ARE FEW ACCESSIBLE
OUTDOOR SPACES.
AND LIKE OTHER PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY I WAS NOT THAT
INVESTED I IN THE OUTDOORS --
BOTH MY PARENTS WORKED FULL TIME
JOBS AND THERE WAS JUST NO ONE
TO TAKE ME OUT ANYWHERE I JUST
TO GO OUTSIDE HOWEVER THAT WOULD
LATER CHANGE WHEN I BECAME A
PARTICIPANT WITHOUT -- OUTRAGE
AT MY HIGH SCHOOL WHERE THEY
EXPOSED ME TO DIFFERENT OUTDOOR
SPACES AND ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD
THEN LEAD TO A STRONG.
CONNECTION BEING DEVELOPED
BETWEEN MYSELF AND THE OUTDOORS
I'M MORE SPECIFICALLY OUR STATE
PARKS.
ALL RIGHT -- I REMEMBER MY FIRST
TIME GOING SURFING ACTIVITY THAT
WE TEACH AT OUR ORGANIZATION
WHERE I HAD A REMEMBER LEARNING
ABOUT THE DIFFERENT TIME AIDS
CURRENTS AND WILDLIFE THAT YOU
WOULD TYPICALLY SEE -- WHILE
DOING THIS ACTIVITY AND I THAT
WAS LIFE CHANGING FOR ME IN THE
WAY THAT PEOPLE FROM MY
COMMUNITY CAN'T AFFORD TO HAVE
SOMEONE ELSE TEACH THEM HOW TO
GO SURFING.
I GET ON THE EQUIPMENT -- AND WE
WERE ABLE TO BRIDGE THAT GAP NOW
COMING FULL CIRCLE ASSN
INSTRUCTOR.
ARE OUT IT IS AN HONOR AND
PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT
FOR OTHER YOUTH IN SAN DIEGO.
WHO ARE IN THE SAME SHOES I WAS
IN NOT TOO LONG AGO -- YOU KNOW
ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE.
MILLIONS OF YOUTH WHO LACK THAT
CONNECTION TO THE OUTDOORS --
AND THAT LACK OF A MEANINGFUL
CONNECTION MEANS THAT -- THERE'S
AN ENTIRE GENERATION OF KIDS WHO
LACK THE EXPERIENCE IS NEEDED --
TO PROTECT ADVOCATE AND FIGHT
FOR THESE OUTDOOR SPACES I WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND FOR THAT REASON --
I AM PROUD TO STAND WITH THE
PARKS NOW COALITION -- TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROPOSITION
SIXTY EIGHT SO THAT PROGRAMS
LIKE AFTER OUT REACH CAN
CONTINUE -- TO BUILD CONNECTIONS
BETWEEN YOUTH AND THE OUTDOORS.
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
RECALL MUSTER THE NOT A WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND WE ARE
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE ARE A MEMBER OF THE PARKS NOW
COALITION AS WELL.
BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN THE STATE
Y. PARK PROGRAM -- AND AS ONE OF
THE PREVIOUS US SPEAKERS
MENTIONED ON THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THAT.
IN TERMS OF EQUITY AN OUT REACH
AND PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT HAS REALLY
BEEN TREMENDOUS -- WE WORK IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
THERE'S STILL A HUGE DISPARITY
OF INCOME.
AND ACCESS THE PARKS THEIR
DIRECT CORRELATION.
SO AS THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID
THIS IS A VERY INSPIRING STORY
THIS IS WHY WE DO OUT REACH TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES SO THAT THOSE
GENERATIONS THOSE KIDS.
GET THAT EXPERIENCE BECOME
FUTURE LEADERS AND AND I JUST
WANNA SAY IT'S INSPIRING TO HEAR
THAT STORY AND SUPPORT THE ON
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
GOOD MORNING -- THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- YOU KNOW FOR FOR HAVING
THIS -- VERY IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION -- MY NAME IS SAMI
NONIUS I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF FATHERS OF FAMILIES
OF SAN JOAQUIN.
LOCATED IN STOCKTON -- I'LL JUST
READING YOU KNOW THAT MISSION
STATEMENT VISION STATEMENT FOR
THE CONSERVANCY THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY AND THE PARKS AND
RECREATION AND I SAW MYSELF IN
IT.
I SARFARYAB LEASE IN AS OUR
COMMUNITY IN THIS MISSION AND
VISION.
THE VISION OR THE MISSION IS TO
ENHANCE THE QUALITY OF LIFE.
BY PROVIDING SAFE WILL MAINTAIN
PARKS AND PUBLIC SPACES
PRESERVING OPEN SPACE AND
HISTORIC RESOURCES CARING FOR
PEOPLE STRENGTHENING THE BONDS
OF COMMUNITY CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU'LL.
GROWTH ENRICHMENT.
I WANT TO JUST SAY -- I'M REALLY
DELIGHTED TO BE HERE WE'VE HAD
SEVERAL CONVERSATION WILL BOTH
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY AS WELL
AS THE PARKS AND RECREATION
DEPARTMENT -- STOCKTON IS THE
LARGE METROPOLITAN CITY TO FILE
FOR BANKRUPTCY AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WAS ABOUT IT WAS A
PUBLIC PARK SYSTEM.
WHICH WAS REALLY THE ABANDONMENT
OF OUR PEOPLE -- AND AND BECAUSE
OF THE THE RED LINING HISTORIC
REDLINING -- AND DESPAIR
TREATMENT I WE'RE ALSO THE PLACE
WAS FUNNY LISTENING TO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT FUNNY HA HA
BUT IT WAS.
KIND OF IRONIC IN A CRUEL IRONY
I FIND MYSELF KIND OF INTERESTED
BY THE CONVERSATION AROUND THIS
LEASE.
AND THE HUB OF THAT BOND THAT
WAS BUNKERS THE LEASE.
AND MAJED WHERE THE PLACE WHERE
GENTRIFICATION WHERE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE BEING GENTRIFIED FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND THE BAY THE
WAY TO BAY AREA ARE AND THE NOT.
AND SO IMAGINE HOW BONKERS IT IS
FOR OUR FAMILIES TO ACTUALLY
HAVE ACCESS TO A THE REGION
THAT'S AN HOUR AWAY OR NOT HAVE
PUBLIC PARKS -- SO WHERE THE
CALIFORNIANS THAT YOU ACTUALLY
ARE TALKING ABOUT TODAY WE JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR BABY SWEAR WE ARE
ELDERS CAN BE RESPECTED.
OUR FAMILIES CAN BE CONNECTED
AND OUR CHILDREN CAN BE
PROTECTED BY PROTECTING THESE
PUBLIC SPACES WHAT FAMILIES GO
TO HEAL.
RIGHT SO IT'S ABOUT HUMANITY
IT'S ABOUT OUR HEALING I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE A TO Z. AS IN
FOR THIS KIND OF IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION IT MEANS SO MUCH TO
US THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI -- I AM YOUR MONEY COME
SURELY AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER BROWN
GIRL SIR.
AND IN AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTEEN
SURFING WAS DECLARED
CALIFORNIA'S STATE SPORT.
HOWEVER IF YOU VISIT THE MANY
SURF BREAKS ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST OF PARKS AND PUBLIC LANDS.
YOU WILL RARELY SEE THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIANS PEOPLE
REPRESENTED IN THE WATER -- THE
CLASSIC IMAGE OF A CALIFORNIA
SURFER REMAINS WHITE AND MALE
AND THERE ARE COMPLEX REASONS
MANY ROOTED IN STRUCTURAL RACISM
AND EXCLUSION. FOR THIS LACK OF
REPRESENTATION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN OF COLOR IN
PARTICULAR IN THE WATER -- BUT
THE DEFAULT ASSUMPTION THIS
CREATES FOR COMMUNITIES IS THAT
WE DON'T BELONG -- ROUND GROCER
OUR ORGANIZATION WORKS TO CHANGE
THIS BY HELPING GIRLS AND WOMEN
OF COLOR CONNECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA COAST.
AND THE SPORT OF SURFING IN A
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY SEE THEIR
LIFE EXPERIENCES REPRESENTED.
ONE YOUNG WOMAN WROTE TO US
AFTER PROGRAM I JUST WANTED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE IN CAPS
NEVER PLAYED IN THE WATER IT
LIKE I DID TODAY AND NEVER HAVE
I EVER BEEN IN WATER WITH SUCH
CONFIDENCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU HAVE
TRANSFORMED ME.
BROWN GROCER RELIES ON FUNDING
FROM THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY EXPLORE THE COAST
PROGRAM TO KEEP OUR PROGRAMS
RUNNING.
WE KNOW THE IMPORTANCE NOT ONLY
OF WELL MAINTAINED PARKS BUT OF
TARGETED SUPPORT FOR COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
THEREFORE I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
BUDGET ALLOCATION FOR PROP SIXTY
EIGHT TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT.
I SUPPORT THE BUDGET ITEMS --
ALLOCATED TOWARDS LOW COST
COASTAL ACCOMMODATION AND I URGE
YOU TO NOT ONLY SUPPORT BUT
CONSIDER INCREASING ALLOCATION
FOR THE EXPLORE THE COAST
PROGRAM OF THE STATE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JUSTIN CORNING
FONG AND I AM A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
ORGANIZATION BROWN GROCER --
BUNGLE SURF WORKS -- TO CONNECT --
GIRLS AND WOMEN PARTICULARLY
GIRLS AND WOMEN OF COLOR TO THE
OCEAN.
AND I I'D REALLY LIKE TO MENTION
THAT AS A CHILD AS A YOUNGER
CHILD -- I DID A LOT OF
IMAGINING OF WHAT I WANT THE
FUTURE TO BE LIKE.
AND IT REALLY WAS NOT UNTIL I
MET AND FOUND BROWN RESEARCH
THAT I CAN ACTUALLY SEE IT.
I'M ON THE WAY OVER HERE MY
SERVING INSTRUCTOR MERA ASKED ME
WHAT MIGHT ONE OF MY FAVORITE
EXPERIENCES WAS.
WITH PROGRESS THERE.
AND INSTANTLY WHAT CAME TO MY
MIND WAS THAT THIS RITUAL WE DO
TO GET READY FOR SURFING AND
WHICH WE ALL HOLD HANDS AND
GOING TO THE WATER TOGETHER WITH
THEIR PORTS ON THE SHORE.
THOUGH SOME OF US HAVE NEVER
LIKE BEEN IN THE WATER BEFORE
AND SOME OF US HAVE BEEN SERVING
FOR YEARS WE ALL STAND THERE
TOGETHER AND ARE PAYING FOR A
GIRL SERVE RASH GUARDS -- AND
THIS MOMENT PARTICULARLY REMINDS
ME OF THE POWER OF UNITY AND THE
POWER AND UNITY [inaudible]
AND WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLE THING
IN ITSELF -- THE PROBLEM WITH
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING ACCESS
IS THAT YOU SIMPLY CANNOT FIGHT
AND STRIVE FOR SOMETHING YOU ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH.
AND SO IN TILL I WAS LUCKY
ENOUGH TO DISCOVER BROWN GIRL
SIR.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT I WAS MISSING
AND SO I HOPE THAT THAT
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE GREATLY OF
KNOWLEDGE AS WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT ACCESS.
AND WHEN WE MAKE THESE DECISIONS
I'M STARTING BUDGET THANK YOU.
HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
GINGER QUIT US I AM HERE
REPRESENTING BROWN GIRL SERVE AS
WELL -- VOLUNTEER SURF
INSTRUCTOR AND TRANSPORTATION
TEAM.
I HAVE COME TO YOU GUYS TODAY
THIS MORNING ALL THE WAY FROM
EAST OAKLAND CALIFORNIA -- I'VE
I'VE HEARD A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT I CAN ALSO AGREE WITH A
FROM THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND
ONE OF THEM WAS COMMUNITY.
ANOTHER WAS HEALING RIGHT NOW
WE'RE IN DESPERATE TIMES TO
PROTECT OUR ENVIRONMENT.
A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO WITH
GIVING ACCESS TO OUR
ENVIRONMENTS INCLUDING OUR COAST
PEOPLE.
WERE GOING TO INHERIT THIS
PLANET AFTER WE ARE LONG GONE.
IT'S A SUPER IMPORTANT FOR US TO
STAND TOGETHER.
AND PROVIDE ENOUGH BUDGET TO
THESE TYPES OF RESOURCES SO THAT.
KIDS LIKE MYSELF WILL COME FROM
THESE NEIGHBORHOODS -- CAN
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT AND LEAVE BEHIND OF
JUST AN AMAZING PLANET FOR OUR
YOUTH AND OUR CHILDREN GOING
FORWARD -- SO WE STAND HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE PROPOSITION AND
THE BUDGET AND DO PLEAD FOR
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION OF
BUDGETING AS WELL.
I'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE WAY THAT
THESE PROGRAMS CAN HEAL OUR
YOUTH.
AND BECAUSE OF THESE INCREDIBLY
TRYING TIMES THAT WE'RE IN
SPECIFICALLY WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES.
I DO ASK THAT EVERYONE IN HERE
NOT ONLY CONSIDER THE BUDGET IN
THE PROP BUT ALSO CONSIDER
RESEARCHING OUR INDIVIDUAL
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED HERE AND SEEING HOW
YOU COULD POTENTIALLY SUPPORTED --
OUR PARKS OR SUPER IMPORTANT TO
US AS WELL THIS IS WHERE WE
CONVENE FOR COMMUNITIES THIS IS
WHERE WE HAVE OUR BIRTHDAY
PARTIES AND THINGS AND AM YOU
KNOW WHERE OUR KIDS CAN GO AND
PLAY SAFELY IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WITHOUT THAT WE HAVE NO HOPE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY ROBINSON
JUNIOR I AM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE EQUITY ORGANIZED A
FATHER THE FAMILY SAM WALKING.
I AM ALSO FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
RESIDENT OF STOCK IN CALIFORNIA
WHO AT THIRTY EIGHT HAD NEVER
BEEN TO A BEACH.
NEVER BEEN TO A COASTAL REGION
NEVER BEEN TO A NATIONAL PARK.
NOW I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT
LACK OF ACCESS TO THE SPACES ARE
THESE AREAS LET ME FROM THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO PUT ON THE
TABLE TODAY IS RECOGNIZING THAT
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH I LEAVE
COME FROM AND WORKING IN?
HOW WE PLAY AND HOW WE PRAY?
THERE'S AN ANALOGY THERE.
RIGHT SO HOW ARE WE SETTING UP
PARKS AS CIVIC ENGAGEMENTS HOW
WE SEVEN PARK THERE SO SUGGEST
THE SPACES WHERE I COMMUNITIES
CAN COME TOGETHER AND POSITIVE
WAYS AND PROSOCIAL WAYS.
AND REHABILITATIVE WAYS AND HAVE
THAT CONNECTION TO NATURE HAVE A
CONNECTION TO THEMSELVES HAVE A
CONNECTION TO HIM.
SO A LOT OF TIMES WE'LL
MARGINALIZE IN THESE COMMUNITIES
I WITH MARGINALIZED MYSELF AND I
THOUGHT THAT MIGHT áREA COLE
WAS WERE REAL ENDEMIC.
MIKE MY GOAL WITHIN REACH BEYOND
A STREET CORNER MY GOAL IS TO
REACH BEYOND A BOT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE WAS A
BEACH.
SO MANY MOUSE FROM STOCKTON
THAT'S WHAT THE STATE AND
STOCKING SO A LOT OF TIMES WILL
BE GIVE A COMMITTEES ACCESS
OUTSIDE OF THE MARGIN OF WHICH
THERE THINKING.
BACK I THINK BIGGER I CAN SAY
THAT I HAVE A MORE.
EXPECT THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
OWNERSHIP OF THE WORLD IN WHICH
I'M LIVING HERE.
RIGHT SO -- HOW TO UTILIZE PARKS
AS RESOURCES HOW DO WE ALLOW OUR
COMMUNITIES ACCESS TO THOSE
RESOURCES A WAY WAS INTERESTING
THAT SOME PEOPLE ARE PUTTING UP
SIGNS BY WE KNOW THE GYM SEE?
TAMAKI PEOPLE OUT.
AND ONE OF THE CONNECTION THAT I
MADE IS SOMEONE RECOGNIZES THE
VALUE OF THE PUBLIC SPACES OF
THESE RECREATIONAL SPACES.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON THEY
RECOGNIZE IT AND NOW YOU WANT TO
KEEP IT AND L<c.cyan>G GRABBED A</c>
KNIFE AND SALES.
TRYING TO KEEP SOME COMMUNITIES
ON THE DECLARE CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES RIGHT GET SOME
COMMITTEE THEY'RE NOT NOTED
EIGHTY SIZE ARE ILLEGAL.
RIGHT SO THEY GET HERE TOMORROW
THE OTHER WAS A DELIGHT WHEN WE
HAVE ACCESS TO SO IT IS IS THE
SAME RIGHT.
THE SPACE IN PLACE THAT WOULD
KIND OF FACE WHICH WAS SOME IS
LIGHTLY ON A NOTICE ON BECAUSE
THEY A GREW UP IN A MORE FLUIDS
TO SAY I HAVE MORE RIGHT.
TO DIFFERENT REGIONS OF THE
WORLD WE ON THE SAME ARE I HAVE
A MORE RIGHT TO RECREATION I
HAVE MORE RIGHT TO PLAY AND
PRAYER AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU ALL TO
CONTINUE TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING I
LIKE THAT THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING JUST
THINKING OF HOW PARK.
IS SOCIAL EQUITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE HOW PART IS CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WE GOT A LOT OF TIME
WE WALK BY A PARK OR YOU DRIVE
BY A PART.
AND YOU SEE THE COMMUNITY PLAN
AND APART YOU CAN KIND OF I'LL
CONSIDER COMMUNITY DO WAY I'LL.
WE KNOW IT IS ALSO EXAMPLES
WHERE WE SWAP BY WE SEE PARKS
AND PEOPLE ARE ON THE ISSUES AND
AND AND IS ALSO WORK TO DO AND
AND APPS MADE BUT WE NEED MORE.
RECREATIONAL PROSOCIAL SPACES AS
PART AND WE NEED TO THINK OF IT
AS THAT.
SO THANK YOU OFFER THAT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SUBCOMMITTEE -- THREE MY
NAME IS LESTER DUNCAN ON THE
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF PROGRAMS WITH
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION BASED
IN SAN DIEGO CALLED OUTDOOR
OUTREACH -- AND IF YOU WOULD
INDULGE ME FOR JUST A MOMENT --
I'D LIKE TO INVITE EACH IF YOU
TO CLOSE YOUR EYES FOR JUST A
FEW SECONDS.
I'M ACTUALLY STILL THIS ACTIVITY
FROM A COLLEAGUE OF MINE -- BUT
I WANT YOU TO IMAGINE YOUR FIRST
THE MOST MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCE
AND OUTDOORS.
WHEN SHOULD IMAGINE THE SITES
YOU SAW?
THE SMELLS BUT YOU TOOK AND THE
THINGS THAT YOU MAY HAVE TOUCH.
THE WILDLIFE THAT YOU MAY HAVE
EXPERIENCE THE SENSE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT YOU MAY HAVE
FELT.
WHILE BEING THERE.
JUST KIND OF GO THERE WITH ME
FIRST ACT.
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MY ONE
OF MY FIRST MOST FIRST THE MOST
MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCES IN THE
OUTDOORS WAS IN MY ADULT LIFE.
CLIMBING MOUNT ST HIS CENTER FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
I REMEMBER GETTING TO THE TOP OF
THE MOUNTAIN LOOKING OUT OVER
THE DESERT LOOKING OUT OVER THE
INLAND EMPIRE.
AND IMAGINING THAT ANYTHING WAS
POSSIBLE.
AS NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
OUTDOOR OUT REACH CREATES THESE
EXPERIENCES -- EACH YEAR FOR
OVER SEVENTEEN HUNDRED YOU AND
THAT YOU'VE HEARD OF FROM THE
PARKS NOW COALITION OF CREATE
THOSE SAME EXPERIENCES FOR YOUTH
ESPECIALLY FOR SOME OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDERSERVED --
YOUTH YOUTH THAT ARE AT RISK OF
A HOST OF INDICATORS IN WHICH
YOU YOU ADDRESS AND OTHER
COMMITTEE MEETINGS -- AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
BY CREATING MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU TO
EXPERIENCE THE OUTDOORS WE'RE
NOT ONLY BUILDING ANOTHER
GENERATION OF CONSERVATIONISTS
THAT WILL TAKE CARE OF AND THAT
WILL STEWART OUR LANDS.
WERE ALSO HELPING TO BUILD THE
HEALTH THE WELL BEING AND THE
RESILIENCE OF OUR COMMUNITIES AS
WELL.
AND SO FOR THAT FOR THAT REASON
OUTDOOR OUT REACH -- PROBABLY
STANDS WITH THE PARKS NOW
COALITION -- TO REALLY ADVOCATE
FOR INTO PUSH SPECIALLY FOR THE
CAN FOR COMMUNITY ACCESS AND
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT FUNDING TO
MAKE OPPORTUNITIES LIKE THIS
POSSIBLE FOR COMMUNITIES AND FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT MAY OTHERWISE NEVER HAVE
THAT EXPERIENCE.
BY CREATING THESE MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCES WERE CHANGING WE'RE
TRANSFORMING OUR COMMUNITIES
THROUGH THE TRANSFORMATIVE POWER
OF THE OUTDOORS -- AND SO I HOPE
THAT EACH OF YOU WILL STAND WITH
US IN THOSE EFFORTS TO DO SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I DON'T THINK --
YOU'LL TAKE THIS AS AN INSULT TO
DIRECTOR BANG IT -- SOMETIMES
THE PUBLIC COMMENT IS MORE
INTERESTING OR AT LEAST AS
INTERESTING AND HELPFUL AS AS AS
THE PRESENTATIONS THAT WE GET
FROM DEPARTMENTS IN THIS I THINK --
WAS CERTAINLY THE CASE MY FIRST
EXPERIENCE BY THE WAY I AT LEAST
THAT I CAN RECALL WAS HIKING IN
THE EATON CANYON AREA OF ABOVE --
AL TO DEAN -- NEAR WHERE I GREW
UP AS A YOUNG PERSON IN MY MOST
RECENT -- I THOUGHT WELL FIRST.
MY MOST RECENT WAS CELL LAST
SUNDAY HIKING -- AND LOOKS TO BE
HONEST PARK -- IN IN IN MY
DISTRICT IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS.
OF WE HAVE -- AS A TRULY --
EXTRAORDINARY -- VARIETY -- AND
AND AND VOLUME OF RESOURCES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE I THINK -- WITH
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TRULY BLESSED TO
HAVE AND IT'S PARTLY HISTORICAL
BECAUSE IF YOU GO TO THE EAST
COAST -- LOT OF THOSE AREAS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE PARKS ARE
PRIVATELY OWNED BECAUSE THE
HISTORY OF THOSE AREAS IS SO
MUCH BETTER WE DO.
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AND
OBLIGATION TO MAKE SURE THAT.
EVERY COULD NOT JUST SADDAM BUT
EVERY CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS. TO
THE FULL BREADTH OF THE THE
BEAUTY AND TO RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE HAVE HERE
AND AND IN THE STATE.
OF SO THANK YOU ALL FOR FOR
THOSE PRESENTATIONS.
ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL THAT ON
HIS REST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
FIRST I WANT TO WELL GO MY DEAR
FRIEND DR LESS FOR DUNCAN
[inaudible]
WORRY LESS.
I'M SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE HE WAS A
SHINING STAR IN SANDRA DINO.
WE LOST HIM TO SAN DIEGO.
BUT WE KNOW THAT IS FOREVER HE
IS IT IS A GREAT PLACE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY HE WAS ALSO WANT
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF OUR THIRTY
UNDER -- THIRTY UNDER REVIEWS
FOR THE FORTY SEVENTH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
ARE HIS WHEREVER HE IS HE ALWAYS
BRINGS IT LIGHT HE BRINGS -- HE
JUST BRINGS EVERYTHING THAT WE
NEED FOR OUR YOUTH AND I'M SO
GLAD FOR SAN DIEGO FOR SO SAID
FOR SAN BERNADINO.
I'M GLAD YOU WERE HERE TO GIVE
YOUR TESTIMONY AND TO THE OTHERS
I THINK THAT.
IT IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT
THAT WE TALK ABOUT AND WE
QUESTION COMMUNITY ACCESS.
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
BEACH IS ABOUT THE COASTAL
COMMUNITY BUT OUR PARKS.
DOESN'T BELONG TO THE STATE TO
BELONGS TO THE PEOPLE.
OF THE PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO IT.
IT MEANS NOTHING IT MEANS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING -- I LIKE THE
COMMENT OF THE GENTLEMAN FROM.
OF THE FATHERS OF SAN JOAQUIN
I'M SORRY DON'T HAVE THIS THE
TITLE.
YES AND AND THAT THERE WERE TWO
SPEAKERS AND ONE OF THEM TALKED
ABOUT HOW WE PLAY AND HOW WE
PRAY. FOR ISN'T THAT THE TRUTH.
BECAUSE IF IT IF FOR ME I DIDN'T
GO TO A BEACH TILL.
PROBABLY MY TEEN YEARS BUT WE
WENT TO THE PARK ON A REGULAR
BASIS.
THAT WAS OUR OUTING - TO BE
ABLE TO GET TO A PARK AND SPEND
TIME WITH FAMILY AND EXTENDED
FAMILY -- ARE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES MUST BE BROUGHT INTO
THE FOLD BECAUSE IF WE DON'T
SUCCEED IN THAT WE ARE LEAVING
GENERATIONS BEHIND.
AND THAT'S WHY SEE YOU HERE SAID
RECOMMENDS SO GLAD YOU'RE HERE.
BECAUSE YOU DO THAT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES YOU MAKE SURE THAT
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE INCLUDED AND
THAT WOULD PLANS FOR PARKS ARE
DONE.
THAT THE COMMUNITY IS INCLUDED
IN THOSE PLANS OTHERWISE THE
CITIES DO NOT GET A NOD.
AND I I APPLAUD YOU FOR THAT SO
I JUST WHAT I WANT TO THANK AYE
MISTER CHAIRMAN I I AGREE WITH
YOU.
THE TODAY IS NO OFFENSE TO THE
REST OF YOU BUT THE PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THAT'S THAT WAS THAT WAS WORTH
STAYING HERE AND MISSING MY NEXT
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MS REVERSE.
THANK YOU AND I WAS PRESENTING A
BILL SO I MISSED THE
PRESENTATION SO I WON'T COMMENT
ON WHO WAS BETTER BUT BUT I'M
YOU KNOW COMMUNITY ACCESS -- IS
AN IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR ME AND MY
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW I GREW UP IN
MY DISTRICT AND NEVER WENT
HIKING AND UNTIL I WAS AN ADULT
RAY AND SO.
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T.
YOU KNOW HAVE ACCESS OR DIDN'T
FEEL WELCOME MEAN -- TO FAMILIES
LIKE MINE -- IN I'M EXCITED
THOUGH THAT THERE'S YOUNG PEOPLE
HERE PRESENTING IN ADDITION --
TO THE ADULTS ON BECAUSE IT
GIVES ME HOPE AND IT INSPIRES ME
THAT.
THIS WILL CONTINUE AND AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT COMMUNITY
ACCESS -- IS PART OF THE
PLANNING OF EVERY PROJECT AND
NOT JUST SOMETHING YOU HAVE TO
DO BECAUSE IT'S REQUIRED -- IT
SHOULD BE PART OF THE PROCESS --
ALWAYS AND SO I JUST WANNA THANK
YOU -- ESPECIALLY THE PRESENTERS
THAT I DID GET -- TO HERE -- IN
YOU KNOW THANK YOU FOR
ADVOCATING FOR THIS.
AS FAR I WAS GONNA SAY THE
MOTION -- JUST BEFORE YOU DO
THAT WILL CLOSE THIS OUT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT.
ALMOST PATTERSON SURE I'M SORRY
I DIDN'T SEE YOUR HAND.
THANK YOU -- ONE TITLE BUT THAT
AIRPLANE.
I WHAT AT UNDERSTAND IT IS AN
ALLEY AT HUSKY.
THAT IS BEING REPLACED ARE YOU
REPLACING IT WITH ANOTHER AB
HUSKY.
SIR BRIAN KAREM WITH THE THE
REAR NOW COASTAL DIVISION BUT
USED TO BE THE SOUTHERN DIVISION.
OUT WE DON'T KNOW WHAT PLAN WILL
BE REPLACING IT WITH WORK WITH
C. H. P. AND OTHER AGENCIES OUT
PLANS RIGHT NOW -- BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT WE DO NOT HAVE THE
TECHNOLOGY WITHIN THE PLAN THAT
WE NEED FOR TODAY'S STANDARDS
LOCATING AND SO.
IT'SGOING TO BE A LOT OF WORK
WITH OKAY PROBABLY FIRE AND C.
H. P. OKAY I REASON I ASK IS --
CHAIR OF THE AVIATION CAUCUS --
BY CAMERA BIPARTISAN.
INTERESTED IN A LOT OF THE
AVIATION DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
HERE WE TALKED ABOUT HELICOPTERS.
FOR CAL FIRE WITH TALKED ABOUT
THE C. WHEN THIRTIES AND OTHERS
AND SO PERIODIC AND ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
PARTIALLY BECAUSE I'M INTERESTED
IN PARTIAL BECAUSE WHEN YOU BUY
A PLANE CAN I GET A RIDE.
AS AN AVIATION CAUCUS.
NOW THERE'S ANOTHER ONE WHERE WE
HAVE LACK OF ACCESS I'M NOT PART
OF THAT.
I DON'T HAVE A PLANE BUT I WANT
TO BE PART OF IT NOW.
SO I ACTUALLY JUST WANT TO CLOSE
THIS OUT BY OBSERVING ONE OF THE
THINGS IT'S ALWAYS AMAZED ME AND
TROUBLED MAY AT WHEN I TALKED --
TO CALIFORNIANS AND ASKED THEM
IF FIVE FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW
FOLKS FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO BIG SUR
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN -- TO COMIC
CHARACTER PARK UP AND NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR YOU KNOW MANY OF
THE OTHER PARKS AROUND THE STATE.
AND IT'S SO COMMON -- TO TO GET
AT THE ANSWER YOU KNOW EVEN
NIGHT THE NATIONAL PARK BUT A
PLACE AS WELL KNOWN AS AN IS
BEAUTIFUL AND EXTRAORDINARY AS
AS YOUR SANITY.
NOW I YOU KNOW MET MANY PEOPLE
HAVE NEVER VISITED THESE PLACES
AND I THINK THAT'S JUST A IT'S A
SHAME BUT I THINK IT'S
PARTICULARLY TRUE -- FOR THE
FOLKS -- THAT ARE REPRESENTED BY
THE GROUPS THAT WERE HERE TODAY --
THAT SOCIAL EQUITY -- A PIECE OF
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO WORK ON I THINK WE HAVE
BEEN MAKING EFFORTS -- MOST OF
THAT EFFORT IS LOCAL IF YOU LIVE
IN LA WE YOU KNOW -- TRY TO GET --
FOLKS FROM THE SOME OF OUR MORE
CHALLENGED A COMMUNITIES OUT TO
THE SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS AND
SOME OF THE OTHER PLACES THAT WE
HAVE AROUND I THINK THOSE ARE
OUT TO THE BEACH -- OF SURFING
AND AND AND WHATNOT -- AND SO
WE'RE MAKING INROADS THERE BUT
ON THE LARGER SCALE NOT SO MUCH
SO JUST IN A AND OBSERVATION FOR
SOMETHING FOR US TO BE THINKING
ABOUT -- NOW AND INTO THE INTO
THE FUTURE WE HAVE -- FIVE ITEMS --
BEFORE CENTER DEPARTMENT OF FOR
PARKS AND RECREATION ANIL.
TO I THINK I I DON'T THINK IS A
REASON WHY WE CAN'T -- ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO DO ALL THESE THE
SAME TIME WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND LET'S VOTE.
BLOOM.
HI FONG.
GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON.
RAY YES.
REVERSE.
THE A WITH A WHICH CUT.
TO THE FIELD TRIP CAUCUS OKAY.
SO WHAT WE NEED ONE MORE CAUCUS --
BUT I OKAY.
WERE.
WERE MAKING PROGRESS I THINK I
NEED TO REIN IN THIS MEETING A
LITTLE BIT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION -- ALWAYS GOOD TO
SEE YOU AND TO WILL MOVE ON NOW
TO DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE.
AGAIN WE HAVE FIVE FIVE ISSUES
UNDER A THIS DEPARTMENT AND THE
A RECOMMENDATION TO HOLD OPEN --
TEN ELEVEN TWELVE AND FOURTEEN
AND TO APPROVE [inaudible]
THIRTY YES.
WITH ACTUALLY WE'VE HAD A
REQUEST WELCOME THE DIRECTOR
ROSS WE'VE HAD A REQUEST TO TAKE --
ITEM -- ISSUE THIRTEEN FIRST OUT
OF ORDER -- BECAUSE WE HAVE A
MEMBER WHO NEEDS.
TO MEN MAY HAVE ALREADY TAKEN
OFF BUT OKAY I'M HAPPY I'M HAPPY
TO DO THAT BUT I HAVE THE
PERFECT SEGUE AFTER ALL THOSE
INSPIRING.
ON THE BIO DIVERSITY INITIATIVE
IT WAS THE PERFECT BRIDGE BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE UP -- ITEM
THIRTEEN WHICH IS OUR TURLOCK
LAP IS THAT CORRECT YES.
RIGHT SO -- ITEM THIRTEEN IS A
PROPOSAL THAT REQUEST. THREE
MILLION NINE HUNDRED FORTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
FOR THE PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
PHASE OF A DESIGN BUILD PROJECT
TO BUILD A NEW FULL SERVICE
CALIFORNIA ANIMAL HEALTH AND
FOOD SAFETY LABORATORY -- AND
THAT NORTHERN PART OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY THIS WOULD
REPLACE OF VERY ANTIQUATED BUT
STILL FUNCTIONAL LAB THAT
CURRENTLY IS IN -- TURLOCK.
THAT LAB SPECIFICALLY SERVES OUR
POULTRY SECTOR WHICH THE PRIMARY
PART OF OUR BOILER INDUSTRY --
TURKEY IS IN THAT PART OF THE
STATE -- THIS IS A PARTICULARLY
RELEVANT ITEM FOR ME TO BRING TO
YOU TODAY BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN
BATTLING FOR HEWLETT NEWCASTLE'S
DISEASE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SINCE MAY OF LAST YEAR.
WE DID HAVE OUR FIRST CONFIRM
FIND -- IN A BACKYARD FLOCK IN
THE EAST BAY AREA JUST A FEW
WEEKS AGO AND SO THE WORK OF
WHAT OUR LABORATORIES.
TO TO PROVIDE -- THE EARLIEST
DIAGNOSTICS DIAGNOSTICS POSSIBLE.
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
IMMEDIATELY TO PREVENT SPREAD OF
THESE KINDS OF ANIMAL DISEASES.
IS CRITICAL TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE HAVE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND OUR ABILITY TO
DELIVER SAFE FOOD FOR ALL OF OUR
CITIZENS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
ACCESS I IMMEDIATELY THINK ABOUT
ALL CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA
HAVING ACCESS. TO SAVE
CALIFORNIA GROWN FOOD TO BE ABLE
TO NOURISH THEMSELVES.
THIS PARTICULAR LAPPETS IN THE
PLANNING PHASE WED AND INCLUDE A
NUMBER OF SERVICES -- FOR BOTH
MAMMALIAN WHICH ARE THE ARE
LARGE ANIMALS AS WELL AS THE
POULTRY SECTOR. TO BE ABLE TO
CONDUCT NECROPSY IS WHICH IS
THAT ABILITY TO DO THE ANALYSIS --
PATHOLOGY BACTERIOLOGY HISTOLOGY
IMMUNOLOGY MOLECULAR BIOLOGY
FOOD SAFETY AND SEROLOGY TESTING
SERVICES I'M AN ENGLISH MAJOR
BUT I WAS ABLE TO GET ALL OF
THAT OUT RIGHT NOW.
THE NEW WORK SITE WILL BE MULTI
FUNCTIONAL SERVING AS A REGIONAL
INCIDENT COMMAND POST WHEN WE DO
HAVE ANIMAL HEALTH DISEASE
RESPONSE SYSTEMS THAT HAVE TO BE
SET UP TO SAVE OUR ANIMAL
POPULATION -- AS WELL AS TO
RESPOND TO FOOD SAFETY OUTBREAKS.
THE WILL TO DIRECTLY BENEFIT OUR
ANIMAL AGRICULTURE SECTOR BY
BEING ABLE TO HAVE THE MOST
STATE OF THE ART.
RAPID DETECTION AND DISEASE
ERADICATION RESPONSE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE NEW FACILITY WILL BE FORTY
ONE THOUSAND SQUARE FEET WHICH
PROVIDES THE SPACE TO DO THE
KINDS OF SERVICES NOT ONLY FOR
THE POULTRY SECTOR BUT AS WELL
AS THE DAIRY SECTOR THAT'S
INCLUDED THERE.
ARE CURRENT FACILITY WHICH GOES
BACK TO I THINK THE NINETEEN
FORTIES.
WITH A COUPLE OF TRAILERS ADDED
ON HAS FIFTY ONE HUNDRED SQUARE
FEET SO YOU CAN SEE THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT INVESTING IN OUR
FUTURE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN
ACCOMMODATE.
ARE ALL SECTORS OF ANIMAL
AGRICULTURE IN THE STATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS DOES THE
LA -- OR FINANCE HAVE COMMENTS.
WHY DON'T WE TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON THIS INDIVIDUAL ITEM SINCE
IT'S THE ONLY ONE WORKING AS TO
VOTE ON TODAY?
I AM SEEING NONE AND I SORT OF A
GOOD LET ME STRETCH THIS OUT
BECAUSE WE'RE WAITING FOR MR
FONG. TO RETURN.
ALL RIGHTS -- THIS IS JUST ISSUE
THIRTEEN RIGHT NOW I'M SORRY YOU
JUST CAME YOU JUST -- YOU WERE
OUT FOR MOST OF THE PRESENTATION
WERE ONLY DOING ISSUE THIRTEEN
RIGHT ONE ON LET'S SEE IF I HAVE
A QUESTION ON THIRTY THINK I TO
PLEASE.
I DO NOT MISTER CHAIR.
IF YOU DON'T MIND WILL PAUSE FOR
A MOMENT AND DISMANTLE ITS.
VOTE ONLY ISSUES ONE THREE SIX
CURRENT VOTES SIX ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE GARCIA.
VOTE ONLY ISSUE SEVEN CURRENT
VOTE FOR TWO CHAIR VOTING AYE
GARCIA.
ITEMS WE HEARD ISSUE FOR CURRENT
VOTE.
ALL RIGHT -- THEN -- WE'RE GONNA
MOVE -- DIRECTLY TO ISSUE TEN
AND THEN WILL WHEN MR FUNG COMES
BACK AS A COURTESY WILL.
GO BACK TO ISSUE THIRTEEN AND
TAKE A VOTE ON THAT ALL RIGHT SO
ISSUE TEN AT THE CALIFORNIA
ABOUT DIVERSITY INITIATIVE --
THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST FOUR
MILLION TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY IN FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND THREE
MILLION NINE HUNDRED ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AT
THE READY AND FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ON
GOING FUNDING WITH EIGHT
POSITIONS TO INITIATE THE
PLANNING AND COORDINATION.
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BIO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE.
A ROAD MAP FOR PROTECTING THE
STATE'S NATURAL HERITAGE.
THIS PROPOSAL ALSO REQUEST
FUNDING. FOR CDF PHASE NOXIOUS
WEEDS AND PROGRAM.
I WANT TO NOTE THAT WHETHER IT'S
IN OUR PARK CENTER PRIVATE
LANCER IN OUR PUBLIC SPACES WE
IT'S AN INVASIVE SPECIES.
ARE HUGELY DESTRUCTIVE TO THE
NATURAL ENVIRONMENT IN ADDITION
TO THE AGRICULTURAL CROPS IT'S
SO THE WORK OF WHAT OUR PLANT
DIVISION CAN -- TO TO ERADICATE
NOXIOUS INVASIVE WEEDS REALLY
WILL HELP PROTECT OUR BIO
DIVERSITY IN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA IS UNIQUE FOR ITS
BEAUTIFUL PARKS AND ITS
LANDSCAPE WHICH INCLUDES I THINK
BEAUTIFUL ACT LAND.
BUT ALSO WE'RE BIODIVERSITY HOT
SPOT BUT IT WON'T STAY THAT WAY
WITH CLIMATE CHANGE FOR NOT MORE
INTENTIONAL ABOUT.
THE ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE ACROSS
ALL DIVISIONS THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. TO PARTNER WITH
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS AS WELL AS
THE WORK THAT WE DO IN PUBLIC
SPACES TO PRESERVE OUR NATURAL
BIO DIVERSITY.
THE GOALS OF THIS PROPOSAL
INCLUDE ESTABLISHING A
CALIFORNIA BIO DIVERSITY
INITIATIVE WORK GROUP WHICH IS
PROPOSED TO BE CO CHAIRED BY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE AS WELL AS THE
SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE.
WE LOOK TOWARDS ACCELERATING AND
STREAMLINING THE PREVENTION
DETECTION AND MANAGEMENT OF
INVASIVE SPECIES AND PASS.
EXPANDING SEED AND GERM PLASM
BANKING AS A HEDGE AGAINST ANY
POTENTIAL PERMANENT LOSS OF
NATIVE PLANT BIODIVERSITY.
AND ESTABLISHING A SOIL CARBON
MAP OF CALIFORNIA.
DUE TO OUR AGRICULTURAL ORIENTED
MISSION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE WE HAVE AN
OUTSTANDING PLANT DIAGNOSTICS
LAB.
AND WE'RE STAFF WITH UNIQUE
EXPERTISE IN SEAT IDENTIFICATION
SEAT PHYSIOLOGY AND SEE QUALITY
ASSESSMENT [inaudible]
CDFA INTENDS TO CONTRIBUTE ITS
EXPERTISE AND TO COLLABORATE OF
OTHER DIVISIONS ACROSS THE
GOVERNMENT.
AS WELL AS ACADEMIA AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THERE ARE MANY
AREAS THAT HAVE STARTED TO DO
THESE KINDS OF COLLECTIONS WE DO
NOT WANT TO DUPLICATE ANYTHING
THAT'S BEING DONE.
BUT WE DO WANT TO BRING OUR
EXPERTISE TO UNDERSTAND WHERE
THE GAPS ARE AND WHAT WE CAN DO
TO ACCELERATE THESE COLLECTIONS
TO MAKE SURE.
WE HAVE DONE EVERYTHING IN THIS
GENERATION. TO PRESERVE OUR
NATIVE BIODIVERSITY SO THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA AND KEEP AT THE
UNIQUE AND BEAUTIFUL SPOT.
YES.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS.
MS REST THIS IS WHERE I HAD THE
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE SURE THAT
THERE ISN'T DUPLICATION IF WE
KNOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA PLANT
RESCUE PROGRAM.
IS CURRENTLY WORKING ON THE THE
BET ON BANKING THE SEEDS -- AND
THEY HAVE FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE OF THE ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR
HOW.
HOW WILL YOU ENSURE THAT YOU'RE
NOT DUPLICATING THEIR EFFORTS SO
OUR STAFF IS ALREADY IN THE
PROCESS OF DOING A CONVENING
WITH THE FOLKS WITH BEEN
INVOLVED IN THAT -- BECAUSE IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL START
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN THE
COMMUNICATION PROCESS
IDENTIFYING WHAT'S IN THE WORKS
WHAT'S IN THE PIPELINE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE DUPLICATING THAT
EFFORT BUT THAT WERE ENHANCING
AT BRINGING IT TOGETHER.
AND AND MAKING SURE THAT WHERE
OUR EXPERTISE AT THE PLANT LAB
IN PARTICULAR CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THAT AND PERHAPS ACCELERATE THAT
WORK THAT WERE IN A POSITION TO
DO THAT.
BUT WE DO NOT INTEND TO
DUPLICATE NONE OF US HAVE EXTRA
RESOURCES TO WASTE.
THAT IS TRUE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE'RE GONNA TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE AND RIGHT
AFTER -- ISSUE FOURTEEN IS HEARD
TO AND SO WHEN WE LAUNCH RIGHT
INTO ISSUE ELEVEN ISSUE ELEVEN
WHICH IS OUR CITRUS PASSED AND
DISEASE PREVENTION.
I'M OF THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR US TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THAT.
ON THIS PROPOSAL REQUEST TWO AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND TO FORTY AND TWO
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS AN
ACCENT AUTHORITY.
AS WELL AS SIXTY FIVE POSITIONS
AND FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND I'M
GOING TO BUILD A DEDICATED
CITRUS PASSED AND DISEASE
PREVENTION DIVISION WITHIN CDFA
TO ENHANCE OUR ASIAN TO SELL IT
AND LONG LONG BEING.
DETECTION AND SUPPRESSION AND
RATIFICATION ACTIVITIES.
THE ONE LONG BEING AS WE'VE
HEARD SEVERAL YEARS SINCE I'VE
BEEN SECRETARY OF AGRICULTURE.
IS THE MOST DEVASTATING OF ALL
STITCHES DISEASES IT HAS BEEN
FOUND IN OTHER NATIONS HAS BEEN
FOUND IN THE STATE OF FLORIDA'S
HAD DEVASTATING MPACTS WE'VE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL THUS FAR IN
KEEPING THE DISEASE OUT OF OUR
COMMERCIAL ORCHARDS AND THAT'S
THE GOAL OF THIS PROGRAM. TO
GIVE US ENOUGH TIME FOR THE
RESEARCH TO FIND THE REAL
SOLUTIONS TO THE DISEASE.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM EXPERIENCE --
AND THE THE PROCESS REST OF OUR
PROGRAM.
THAT WE REALLY WILL BE BEST
SERVED BY HAVING A DEDICATED
CITRUS DIVISION.
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO HANDLE THE
FINES THAT WERE HAVING. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE TRAINED EXCLUSIVELY AND
CITRUS DISEASE RESPONSE.
AND NOT MOVING PEOPLE FROM OTHER
EMERGENCY PROGRAMS TO FOCUS ON
VAST WHICH MAKES US VULNERABLE
IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND TAKES RAMP
UP TIME TO MOVE PEOPLE AROUND
INTO THE TRAINING -- THIS IS
ALSO IMPORTANT TO US BECAUSE
CITRUS WELL IT'S NOT OUR LARGEST
PROP IT IS OVER THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND AS A PART OF OUR HISTORY
IT'S AN ICONIC GOODWILL
AMBASSADOR TO THE WORLD ARE
FRESH AND BEAUTIFUL AND TASTY.
AS WELL AS NUTRITIOUS ADDRESS.
SO THAT IS OUR PROPOSAL GOING
FORWARD -- WE HAVE HAD IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS SOME ONE
TIME INVESTMENTS IN THIS PROGRAM
WHICH OF REALLY HELPED US.
ON REALLY -- IMPROVING OUR
DIAGNOSTICS FOR RAPID DETECTION
AND THEN GOING OUT AND BEING
ABLE TO REPLICATE ONCE WE GET A
TIME WE NOW HAVE ALMOST TWELVE
HUNDRED TREES THAT ARE POSITIVE.
THAT HAVE BEEN FOUND IN A PRETTY
CONFINED AREA AND THE SOUTHERN
LA BASIN AREA -- AND AND WHAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO DO WITH
THOSE ONE TIME EXPENDITURES IS
DO THE PLANNING.
AND HIRING OF STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO GO FORWARD ON THAT ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES MAKE IT VERY
CHALLENGING TO DO THE ADEQUATE
KIND OF PLANNING.
THAT ALIGNS WITH OUR STRATEGIC
PLAN AND THE INVESTMENT IN
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THIS SO WE FEEL THAT WITH THIS
REQUEST THIS YEAR WERE IN THE
BEST POSITION WE HAVE BEEN. TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A DEDICATED
DIVISION DEVOTED TO THE CITRUS
DISEASE PROGRAM.
IT'S GREAT -- TO IT IS -- I
THINK OF A PRESSING ISSUE AND
I'M.
GLAD THAT WERE A REORGANIZING
AND CONTINUING TO PROVIDE TO OF
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NECESSARY
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
PLEASE RATES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'M SURE THE TROOPS ALL THE
LETTER OF THE OPPOSING LETTER
BUT NOT SO MUCH OPPOSING WHICH
REQUESTING BUT EXPRESSING A REAL
CONCERN ABOUT -- THE PESTICIDE
SPECIFICALLY -- M..
AND THE EFFECT ON OUR HONEY BEES.
IN IN MY PARTICULAR REGION HONEY
BEES ARE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT I'M
SURE THERE ARE EVER WORLD -- ONE
OF THE AVAILABLE OPTIONS -- THAT
ARE BEING LOOKED AT AT THE
LOOKED AT SPECIFICALLY REGARDING
THE THE PESTICIDES SO THEY DON'T
AFFECTED NOT -- NOT ONLY THAT
THE LAND BUT ALSO THE PEOPLE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND OTHER
BENEFICIAL SAP THAT'S THAT'S A
GREAT QUESTION I HAVE NOT SEEN
THE LETTER BUT I HAVE HEARD
ABOUT IT.
AND IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
QUESTION TO BE ASKING BECAUSE
ONE OF THAT THE PROCESS IS THAT
WE GO THROUGH WHEN WE HAVE A
FIND OF AN INVASIVE PASSED.
IS THAT WE WANT TO A RATHER IT
IS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE TO
PREVENT EXTENSIVE PESTICIDE USE
IF IT WERE TO BECOME INFESTED.
AND THEN HAVE TO BE A PART OF
EVERY INDIVIDUAL FARMERS PEST
MANAGEMENT WITCHY.
SO OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND
QUICKLY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT AND
THERE ARE MANY STEPS WE TAKE AS
A RESULT OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT ANALYSIS THAT WAS DONE TO
COVER THESE KINDS OF PROGRAMS.
IT'S ALL ABOUT INTEGRATED PEST
MANAGEMENT WE FIRST LOOK AT HOW
DO WE NOT DOWN THE IMMEDIATE
POPULATION.
WHAT ARE THE ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO US CAN IT BE
MECHANICAL LIKE?
UP PULLING OUT A TREE OR OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
WHAT ARE THE TOOLS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THAT ARE BIOLOGICAL AS
WELL AS CHEMICAL WHAT ARE THE
SOFTEST TOOLS THAT WE CAN USE
AND STILL GET A RESULT? TO KEEP
THE INFESTATION FROM SPREADING
TO LARGER GEOGRAPHIC AREAS SO WE
GO THROUGH THOSE I PM PROCESSES.
EARLY IN WHAT LOOKS LIKE IT'S
GOING TO BE A PROLONGED
INFESTATION AND THIS IS -- CURT
WITH OUR CITRUS DISEASE PROGRAM
ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS WE DO ON
RESEARCH IS TO START TO IDENTIFY
BIOLOGICALS WHAT ARE BENEFICIAL
PASS.
NORMALLY WE HAVE TO GO OUT TO
AREAS OF ORIGIN I BELIEVE THIS
PARTICULAR WHAT'S CAME FROM
PAKISTAN.
SO IT TAKES TIME TO DEPLOY
PEOPLE TO GO TO WHERE THEY MIGHT
BE ABLE TO FIND IT BENEFICIAL.
THAT CAN BE BROUGHT IN MAKE SURE
THAT GOES THROUGH THE STEPS TO
MAKE SURE IT DOESN'T PROVIDE.
ANY UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES AND
THEN DO BREEDING CYCLES TO HAVE
ENOUGH TO RUN PILOT PROGRAMS.
SO WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL EARLY
ON A LOT OF THIS WORK HAPPENED
WITH PEOPLE FROM UC RIVERSIDE --
THAT SPECIALIZE IN AND GOING TO
THESE AREAS OF ORIGIN TO
IDENTIFY WHAT'S GOING TO WORK WE
HAVE A WASP IT'S CALLED TAMARIX
SCEA.
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DEPLOY --
EXTENSIVELY I WANT TO MAKE SURE
I'M CLEAR WE HAVE REARED AND
RELEASED OVER THREE MILLION OF
THESE WASP AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
AND OVER THE LIFETIME THAT WE'VE
HAD THESE WHAT'S IN THE BREEDING
CYCLES FOR DEPLOYMENT.
WE'VE RELEASED OVER ELEVEN
MILLION SINCE THE INCEPTION OF
BEING ABLE TO DO THIS BIOLOGICAL
CONTROL.
WE ALSO CONSTANTLY COME BACK AND
CHECK TO MAKE SURE THERE ARE NO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
AS WELL AS FOR US WE REALLY NEED
TO CONFIRM THAT THEY ARE
ESTABLISHED AND THAT THEY'RE
DOING WHAT WE WANTED TO DO WHICH
IS THIS BENEFICIAL LAST.
TAKING CARE OF OF THE ASIAN SIT
JUST SELL IT.
AND WE HAVE -- FOUND
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE TERRORISTS
YET OVER EIGHTY LOCATIONS SO
THAT SHOWS IS THAT WE HAVE A
BENEFICIAL THAT'S BECOMING
ESTABLISHED TO BE ABLE TO COME
BACK THIS INVASIVE PASSED THE
ASIAN CITRUS SELECT.
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE WAYS I
THINK IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE
WE'VE DONE THIS FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS FARM THAT FLIGHT
PROGRAM.
WHEN I FIRST MOVED TO THIRTY
YEARS AGO WE USE HELICOPTERS TO
FLY MALATHION?
HAPPY TO SAY WE'VE MOVED PAST
THOSE DAYS WITH STERILE RELEASE
OF MED FLIES SO THAT ON ANY
GIVEN WEEK WE'RE RELEASING OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
MILLION STERILE MED FLIES -- TO
BREED IF THERE IS AN INFESTATION
THAT INFESTATION OUT OF THAT
CYCLE THEY FLY OVER AT ABOUT.
TWO THOUSAND FEET SO WE'VE
LEARNED FROM ALL OF OUR PROGRAM
SO THAT IF WE FIND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A PROLONGED
INFESTATION WE CAN BEGIN THAT
KIND OF BIOLOGICAL RESEARCH
IMMEDIATELY.
HAD TO COST YES.
YES MA'AM.
THAT'S A LOT OF STERILE MED
FLIES A LOT LOT OF LOS.
YEAH I AM.
I HAVE AN ALLERGY TO US WITH A
THAT A LITTLE BIT OF A NIGHTMARE
THERE HAD DISCUSSION -- BUT THE
LEASING THIS -- WE SEEM THEY SEE
P. SHOW UP IN MY DISTRICT AND
SPREAD AND SO MY CONSTITUENTS
ARE DEFINITELY PAYING ATTENTION
AND CONCERNED -- FOR THEIR OWN
CONSUMPTION MUCH LESS WELL I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT IT COULD
HAVE TO OUR BIGGER AGRICULTURAL.
COMMUNITY OUT THERE WE'VE SEEN
TREES THAT ARE BEING UPROOTED AN
ANIMATIC HATED IN THE MOMENT BUT
THE STATE HAS CONTINUED AND SO.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
PROTECTING HUMAN HEALTH ALONG
THE WAY BUT WERE YOU SIGNALED IS
POSSIBLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T.
WE WE GET THIS UNDER CONTROL AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO IT'S IT'S
STARTED IN ONE OF MY CITIES
TONIGHT IN MULTIPLE OF MY CITIES
UNTIL.
NEIGHBORS ARE DEFINITELY A
LITTLE FREAKED OUT ABOUT THEIR
TREES LEVY IN -- AND I KNOW THAT
THAT'S A SMALLER PART OF THE
WORRY THAT WE HAVE ON IN THIS
ECOSYSTEM.
AND SO ON I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WELL I PREFER THEN BIOLOGICALS
THAT WERE YOU SEEN EVERYTHING
AND ARE DISPOSABLE TO MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T GET OUT OF CONTROL
AND WE THEN REALLY PUT AT REST
THE BIGGER AGRICULTURAL.
MARKET THAT WE HAVE THAT'S AND
PUT INTO ECONOMY HERE.
AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE --
YOU KNOW RULE IN IRVINE
CALIFORNIA ARE SO INTER
CONNECTED AND INTERDEPENDENT BUT
MANY OF THESE INFESTATIONS DO
OCCUR IN AN URBAN SETTING.
AND SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE DO GOOD COMMUNICATION AND
OUTREACH AND CONSULTATION IN
TOWN HALL MEETINGS -- SO THAT
ARE URBAN NEIGHBORS AND
CONSUMERS -- FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH WHAT WE'RE DOING AND THAT
THEIR CONCERNS HAVE BEEN LISTEN
TO BECAUSE THAT THAT'S A TRUST
RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE TO
MAINTAIN AND I'VE SPENT A YOU
KNOW A DAY WALKING WITH THE
FOLKS WHO DID HAVE TO REMOVE
TREES AND IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO
SEE SOMEONE'S.
ORANGE TREE THAT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PLANTED BY THEIR GRANDFATHER OR
SOMETHING HAVE TO BE UPROOTED
THE SUCH AT CITRUS INDUSTRY'S
BEEN VERY GENEROUS AND TRYING.
TO DO REPLACEMENTS WHERE THAT'S
POSSIBLE BUT I HAVE TO SAY IT IS.
AMAZING HOW C<c.cyan> OPERATIVE THE</c>
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN AND I CAN'T
SAY ENOUGH GOOD ABOUT THAT KIND
OF COOPERATION THAT'S WHAT MAKES
CALIFORNIA WORK THAT'S WHEN WE
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN HELP EACH
OTHER AND SERVE ONE ANOTHER.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
LET'S -- TAKE A SECOND AND GO
BACK -- TO ISSUE THIRTEEN MISERY
THIS NEEDS TO LIVE AND IF WE CAN
GET A MOTION ON THE TABLE LARA.
BLOOM HI FONG GARCIA.
MULLIN PATTERSON RIGHT YES
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU -- AND THANK YOU FOR A
A BRING UP THE INDUSTRY BECAUSE
OF THE THE TOPIC OF OF HONEY
BEES AND COLONY COLLAPSE
DISORDER AND THE NEO NEXT GOOD.
TAUGHT IN THE NEONICOTINOID --
ISSUE THOSE ARE ALL KIND OF
PERCOLATING OUT THERE AND
THEY'RE IMPORTANT BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT -- CITRUS
TREES CAPTION -- A WITHOUT
POLLINATION POLLINATION
TYPICALLY IS COMING FROM FROM
BEES AND TO SO I I THINK THAT --
WE ALL SHARE AND IT A AND
INTEREST IN RESOLVING THE THIS
KIND OF ISSUE AND IN A WAY THAT --
TO WORKS FOR EVERYONE YES AND
AND THAT THAT'S BEEN THE OUR
CONSULTATION PROCESS WITH DPR AS
WELL AS E. HA ON PUBLIC HEALTH
AS WELL AS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
WE ALSO DO A CONSULTATION WITH
FIELD.
FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE'S --
AND THE NEO NECKS ARE USED IN
ACCORDING WITH THE CRITERIA TO
PREVENT IMPACTS TO BEES IN
ADDITION TO ALL THE OTHER.
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE BUT I ALSO
HAVE TO THINK THIS COMMITTEE THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR BROWN
LAST YEAR FOR THE INVESTMENT IS
BEING MADE IN OUR BE SAFE
PROGRAM.
SO THAT WE CAN GET BEE HIVES
REGISTERED TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
NOT BEING PLACED IN PLACES THAT
ARE NOT.
NOT A COMPATIBLE WITH THE CROPS
THAT MAYBE USING PESTICIDES SO
WE'RE MAKING A CONSIDERABLE
INVESTMENT BECAUSE THESE ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUR ALMOND BLOOM EACH
YEAR IS LITERALLY THE WORLD'S
LARGEST.
POLLINATION PROJECT WHEN IT
OCCURS -- SO BEES MATTER TO
CALIFORNIA AND TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AS WELL AS BEING AN
IMPORTANT PART.
OF JUST.
MAKING OUR ENVIRONMENT AND OUR
ECOSYSTEMS HOLE.
ALSO A DEMONSTRATION OF HOW
FRAGILE OUR ECOSYSTEMS COMMITTEE
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SOME OF THESE
ISSUES -- LA -- I THINK YOU'VE
GOT SOME COMMENTS ON THIS YES
THANK YOU SEAN MARTIN OF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AND
SO WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
GIVING THIS.
THAT THAT RECENT INCREASES IT.
AND THE SPREAD OF BOTH ASIAN
CITRUS WELLAND ANIMAL LONG ON
BEING IN THE GROWING NUMBERS OF
TREES INFECTED WITH ONE LINE
BANG OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS --
WE THINK THE REQUEST FOR THE
ADDITIONAL STAFF AND RESOURCES
FOR THE DEDICATED DIVISION IS
REASONABLE -- WE ALSO
RECOMMENDED THAT YOU REQUIRE
CDFA TO REPORT ON THEIR CURRENT
YEAR EXPENDITURES -- AS PART OF
OUR ANALYSIS WE NOTED THAT THEY
WEREN'T PLANNING ON SPENDING
SOME OF THE FUNDS THAT WERE
APPROPRIATED TO THEM IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
AND THEN THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT ARE IN YOUR
AGENDA THAT WE RECOMMEND YOU GAS
TO DEPARTMENT I BELIEVE THEY'VE
ALREADY ADDRESSED SOME OF THEM.
THANK YOU I HATE WHEN YOU
DISAGREE WITH OUR STAFF
RECOMMENDED.
THAT -- WE'RE NOT TOO FAR APART
HERE BUT THE RECOMMENDATIONS TO
HOLD OPEN SO WILL -- I WILL DO
THAT -- AND WHEN WE ALLOW --
MISTER FUNK TO ADD ON TO ISSUE
THIRTEEN BECAUSE I THINK HE'S
NEEDS TO RUN.
ISSUE THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTE FOUR
ZERO CHAIR VOTING I FONG.
WELCOME LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
TWELVE AND AND TWELVE ORTEZ
FOURTEEN DOES DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
HAVE A BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THAT I DON'T THINK
WE'RE UNIQUE AGENCY IN THAT
REGARD -- THIS SPECIFIC REQUEST
FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AS FOR THREE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO ADDRESS WHAT WE
PRIORITIZE AS CRITICAL
STRUCTURAL DEFICIENCIES. ONE IS
IN OUR HAWAIIAN -- FRUIT FLY
REARING FACILITY AND THE OTHERS
FOR A PLANT.
PAST DIAGNOSTIC CENTER WHICH IS
LOCATED HERE IN SACRAMENTO --
OUR HAWAIIAN FRUIT FLY REARING
FACILITY I'VE ALREADY MENTIONED
ABOUT THE WONDER OF OUR THAT
FLIGHT PROGRAM WITH THE RELEASE
OF STILL FLIES.
THE BREEDING FACILITY IS IN
HAWAII -- AND IT IS IN DESPERATE
NEED OF IMPROVED CLIMATE CONTROL
I THINK THAT'S ACCURATE FOR
BEACH RIGHT KEVIN.
ON HEATING AND COOLING -- IT'S
VERY INTERESTING THIS PROCESS
THAT WE GO THROUGH.
AND WITH IMPROVED -- CLIMATE
CONTROL IN THIS FACILITY IT WILL
ENSURE THAT ONLY THE CONTINUED
AVAILABILITY BUT HOPEFULLY
IMPROVED AVAILABILITY OF NUMBERS
AS WELL AS QUALITY OF THE FRUIT
FLIES.
ON BETTER THAN BROUGHT OVER TO
OUR FACILITY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BEFORE THEY'RE
DEPLOYED SO THAT'S WHAT THAT
PARTICULAR ONE IS -- FOR THE
SECOND ONE IS FOR A PLANT PASSED
DIAGNOSTIC LAB -- I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT AN INVESTMENT FOR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE TO A STOP
ARE LEAKING ROOF FROM LEAKING
LAST YEAR.
THAT WORK HAS FINALLY BEEN
COMPLETED HOWEVER.
WE'RE STILL HAVING WATER
INTRUSION PROBLEMS MOSTLY AROUND
WINDOW SILLS.
AND GIVEN THE INVESTMENT THAT WE
MAKE AND HIGHLY SOPHISTICATED
AND SENSITIVE DIAGNOSTIC
EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS THE QUALITY
OF THAT WORK SPACE FOR EMPLOYEES
WE WANT TO FINISH THE JOB THAT
WAS STARTED BY GETTING THE ROOF
DONE AND NOW FINISHING THESE%
OTHER AREAS OF WATER INTRUSION.
GET THAT FINISH SO THOSE TWO
PROJECTS ARE THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TO FOR ME.
THAT IS THE WHOLE Y. E..
WHERE LIKE THAT THE WHOLE WIFE
REPLY REARING FACILITY IS THAT
AND WHY IT IS IN HAWAII
SOMETHING THAT THE FIELD TRIP?
I WAS TALKING TO SAY I WAS GOING
TO OFFER TO FIELD TRIPS FOR YOU
ONE WOULD BE TO HAWAII SHOULD
YOU HAVE OTHER BUSINESS THERE.
AND THE OTHER ONE IT'S JUST IT
IS FASCINATING TO GO TO THE
FACILITY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO VISIT IT'S AT THAT'S ANOTHER
IT'S A LOT OF TRAILERS ALL
HOOKED UP TOGETHER U. S. T. A.
KEEPS PROMISING ELSEWHERE ON THE
HIGH PRIORITY LIST. FOR UPDATING
THAT FACILITY BUT JUST TO SEE
THE DEDICATION OF OUR EMPLOYEES
AND ALL THE WORK THAT THEY DO.
TO GROW THESE FRUIT FLIES OUT
AND THEN LOAD THEM ONTO THESE
PLANES IT'S A PRETTY FASCINATING
THAT WILL BE ADDRESSING THAT I I
ENJOY A VISIT TO THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FACILITY AND EXTEND
THE INVITATION TO THE REST OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE -- AND TO
FOURTEEN ISSUE FOURTEEN CATS YES.
SO -- THE FIRST PART OF THIS AS
A TECHNICAL REQUEST THAT WOULD
CONVERT SIX BLANCA POSITIONS TO
PERMANENT POSITIONS.
NO FUNDING ASSOCIATED THIS WE
JUST NEED THE AUTHORITY FOR THE
CONVERSION OF THOSE.
POSITIONS.
OUR NEXT ONE DEALS WITH THE
FEDERAL MILK MARKETING ORDER AND
A QUOTA IMPLEMENTATION PROGRAM
ESTABLISHMENT.
OF THE DAIRY SECTOR VOTED OVER A
YEAR AGO -- TO LEAVE AS STATE
MILK MARKETING ORDER AND NOT
PULLING PROGRAM TO JOIN A
FEDERAL MILK MARKETING ORDER.
THAT ACTUALLY TOOK A FACT IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CONCURRENTLY THE INDUSTRY VOTED
TO CONTINUE A CALIFORNIA ONLY
QUOTA IMPLEMENTATION PROGRAM --
WHAT THAT NECESSITATES IS THIS
REQUEST FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND
NINETY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND
ACT FUND OF?
FORTY A REDUCTION OF THIRTY FOUR
POSITIONS AND TWELVE AT TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON GOING TO
CLOSE THE DERRY MARKETING BRANCH.
AND THE MILK POOLING BRANCH DUE
TO THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THIS
FEDERAL MILK MARKETING ORDER --
CDFA WOULD RETAIN FIVE POSITIONS
FROM THE CLOSING BRANCHES TO
ESTABLISH A QUOTA IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM.
THE FUNDING WILL ALLOW CDFA TO
COMPLY WITH THE REFERENDUM THAT
PUT THIS QUOTE IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM IN PLACE.
I WILL BE THE FIRST ONE TO SAY
IT HAS BEEN A CHALLENGING YEAR
IT IS VERY HARD TO LOSE PEOPLE
WHO DEDICATED LARGE PARTS OF
THEIR CAREERS. TO REALLY
UNDERSTANDING THE DAIRY SECTOR
AND IMPLEMENTING THAT PROGRAM
AND DOING IT IN A VERY
PROFESSIONAL WAY.
AND I HAVE TO COMMEND THEM FOR
THE PROFESSIONAL WAY THAT WE
HAVE CLOSED DOWN THIS PROGRAM --
IN ORDER TO TRANSITION TO A
FEDERAL MILK MARKETING ORDER
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE UP FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS DAIRY
INDUSTRY.
THE NEXT WHAT PART OF THIS IS
OUR MOUNTAIN PASS BORDER
PROTECTION STATION -- AND AN
OPERATIONS EXPANSION THIS IS A
FAIRLY NEW FACILITY THAT WE
BUILT TO ACCOMMODATE OUR FAST
GROWING POPULATION.
OF THE PROPOSAL REQUEST SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND GENERAL FUND AT THE
ALREADY.
AND EIGHT POSITIONS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ON GOING TO
OPERATE THIS NEW BORDER
PROTECTION STATION IN MOUNTAIN
PASS.
WITH THE VEHICLE TRAFFIC
EXCEEDING EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
ON I. FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ADDITIONAL CDF.
A STAFF IS NEEDED TO PERFORM
STATE MANDATED INSPECTION.
FAST ENOUGH TO PREVENT MASSIVE
TRAFFIC BACKUPS ON I FIVE WHICH
THE PRESENTS A PUBLIC SAFETY
HAZARD.
AS WELL AS COULD START TO CAUSE
PEOPLE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO
DIVERT AROUND THESE BORDER.
INSPECTION STATIONS THE STATIONS
ARE PART OF OUR PAST EXCLUSION
ACTIVITIES SO THEY'RE ACTUALLY
VERY CRITICAL TO OUR WHOLE
SYSTEM.
SINCE MOUNTAIN PASS STATION OPEN
IN AUGUST OVERNIGHT TRAFFIC
PATTERNS HAVE NEAR THOSE OF THE
OLD YOUR MOST STATION.
IN THE MONTH OF SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER AND NOVEMBER OVER ONE
POINT THREE MILLION VEHICLES AND
OVER ONE THOUSAND BOATS HAVE
TRAVELLED THREE MOUNTAIN PASS.
OF THIS TOTAL ELEVEN POINT 3% OR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
HAVE BEEN DURING THE OVERNIGHT
HOURS -- BY -- DURING THE
OVERNIGHT HOURS A SEPTEMBER
OCTOBER NOVEMBER THIS YEAR HIGH
RISK INSPECTIONS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED.
TO THE ONE IN BASIC PASS BEING
INTERCEPTED AND THIRTY SEVEN
NOTICES OF REJECTION BEING
ISSUED AT THE STATION.
FUNDING IN POSITIONS FOR
ADDITIONAL LANES TO BE OPEN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS IS VITAL TO
HELP REDUCE THE DANGEROUS
TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
AND LINES AT THE MOUNTAIN PASS
STATION THAT OCCURRED DURING THE
OVERNIGHT HOURS.
AND THEN CONTINUING ON THIS VERY
LONG TECHNICAL.
SORRY IF IF YOU WERE TO CHOOSE
TO BE A LITTLE BIT BRIEFER.
OKAY WOULD YOU WOULDN'T GET ANY
PUSH BACK FROM THE CHAIR OKAY.
UP TO MY DEATH.
I BECAUSE I'M SURE THERE'S A
LONG LINE OF ADVOCATES WAITING.
TO THE OFFICE OF INFORMATION
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES IS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT OP FOR
IMPLEMENTING SOME MANDATES
ACROSS ALL AGENCIES AS NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN ADMINISTRATION AUTHORITY AND
ONE POSITION AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONE POSITION
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OF THIS IS FOR
THE OPERATION OF OUR NETWORK AND
SECURITY INFRASTRUCTURE TO MY
GREAT ARE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT.
DEPARTMENTS TECHNOLOGIES TENET
MANAGED SERVICES DATACENTER
ENVIRONMENT AS REPLACE CRITICAL
EQUIPMENT THAT HAS REACHED THE
END OF ITS USEFUL LIFE -- THE
NEXT ITEM IS -- DEVELOPMENT OF
PESTICIDE ALTERNATIVES -- THIS
IS A PROPOSAL THAT REQUEST SIX
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS AB ACT FUNDED THIRTY AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON
GOING FAR OFFICE OF PESTICIDE
CONSULTATION AND ANALYSIS TO
SUPPORT THE SCIENTIFIC
DEVELOPMENT.
OF BIOLOGICAL CONTROL EFFORTS
AND THE TESTING OF ALTERNATIVES
FOR PESTICIDES.
BAD ARE UNDER PRESSURE FOR THE
REGISTRATION OR ADDITIONAL
MEDICATION MEASURES WHERE WE
ASSIST IN FINDING ADDITIONAL --
SOFTER USE OF BIOLOGICAL BASED
SOLUTIONS TO PESTICIDES I'M HERE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
LAST YEAR -- THE OFFICE RECEIVE
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT FOR FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO BEGIN THE SUCH
SCIENTIFIC DEVELOPMENT FOR
PESTICIDES -- AND THIS WOULD
EXPAND OUR ABILITY TO MORE PRO
ACTIVELY IDENTIFY BIOLOGICAL
CONTROLS AND FIND AT LEAST --
THREE TO FOUR I ARE FOR RESEARCH
PROJECTS TO FIND ALTERNATIVES
FOR SPECIALTY CROPS SECTOR.
INDUSTRIAL HEMP PROGRAM IS A
REQUEST FOR SIX POSITIONS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AN ON
GOING FOR THE DEVELOPMENT AND
FORCE MEANT.
AND ADMINISTRATION OF THE
INDUSTRIAL HEMP PROGRAM.
WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE
INDUSTRIAL HEMP FARMING ACT IT
DOES REQUIRE -- THAT FEES BOB BE
COLLECTED AND DEPOSITED IN THE
AG FUND AND THAT THEY BE
CONTINUOUSLY APPROPRIATED. TO
COVER THE COSTS OF IMPLEMENTING
THIS.
THIS PROGRAM -- AS A SIDE NOTE
OUR REGISTRATION REGULATORY
PACKAGES AT THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW AND WE EXPECT --
TO HAVE FINAL REGULATIONS IN
PLACE EARLY SPRING HOPEFULLY BY
THE SECOND WEEK OF APRIL FOR THE
FULL REGISTRATION PROGRAM TO
BEGIN.
AND THEN FINALLY WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL -- REQUEST FOUR
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND AT THE
READY AND ONE POSITION STARTING
IN -- NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX TO
ADMINISTER CDF FACE FUNCTIONS
THAT REQUIRED THAT WERE REQUIRED
BY TWENTY EIGHT LEGISLATION --
TO COORDINATE AND CONSULT WITH
CAL CAL EPA CAL RECYCLE.
ON ORGANIC WASTE TO COMPOST AND
I HOPE THAT WAS STARTED.
GREAT -- LA -- I KNOW YOU HAVE
SOME COMMENTS.
MARTIN AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AS WE AGREE
WITH THE STAFF ASSESSMENT AS
NOTED IN THE AGENDA THAT THAT
MANY OF THE PROPOSALS BEFORE YOU
TODAY ARE NOT TECHNICAL IN
NATURE -- WE'RE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DIRECT
ADMINISTRATION TO REVERT TO THE
LONG STANDING PRACTICE OF
SUBMITTING STANDALONE BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSALS A SPECIFICALLY
FOR PROPOSALS THAT INCLUDE NEW
POSITIONS FUNDING FOR NEW
ACTIVITIES.
AND OR EXTENSIONS OF FUNDING --
THIS WILL BETTER ENABLE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXERCISE ITS
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION BECAUSE IT
WILL HAVE A MUCH MORE COMPLETE
PICTURE OF THESE PROPOSALS A
SICKLY WERE RECEIVING ONE PAGE
DESCRIPTIONS OF THESE PROPOSALS.
INSTEAD OF LARGER DOCUMENTS THAT
CONTAIN ADDITIONAL FISCAL
INFORMATION -- SO THAT'S A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS ISSUE WE
WILL SAY THAT WE REQUESTED THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE DEPARTMENT
WHEN WE DID THEY WERE VERY
FORTHCOMING WITH THE INFORMATION.
THANK SENT -- WE WILL ADOPT YOUR
RECOMMENDATION -- DIRECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION IF FOR NO OTHER
REASON THAN IT'S EVERY ONCE IN
AWHILE IT'S GOOD TO THINK THAT I
CAN ACTUALLY CAM DIRECT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
ABOUT I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT
STRUCTURALLY YOU KNOW FOR OUR
PURPOSES HERE THAT WE AT HERE TO
THAT -- TO TO THAT PRACTICE AND
ALLIN ALL SERIOUSNESS -- F.
BROTHERS NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ALL OF THE CDFA
ISSUES -- TEN THROUGH.
FOURTEEN GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ON I MADE HER
GENDER FROM PESTICIDE ACTION
NETWORK ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
REFORM.
HLB DISEASE IS CERTAINLY A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR THE STATE TO
ENFORCE ADDRESS.
HOWEVER WHAT CDFA IS DOING IS
FOCUSING JUST ON PRESS CONTROL
AND THAT IS IMPORTANT IN THE
SHORT TERM IT'S A SHORT TERM
MEASURE.
BUT FOR LONG TERM DISEASE
CONTROL YOU NEED TO INCREASED
INCREASED PLANTERS ALIENS YOU
NEED TO DO DISEASE MANAGEMENT
AND THAT REQUIRES A DIFFERENT
KIND OF APPROACH ON A DIFFERENT
KIND OF STAFFING.
WHICH IS WHY WE ARE OPPOSING THE
CURRENT BUDGET PROPOSAL CHAIN
PROPOSAL UNLESS IT IS AMENDED.
TO INCLUDE A AN EXTRA MILLION
DOLLARS FOR MORE STAFF WHO ARE
HAVE SPECIALTY EXPERTISE IN THE
KINDS OF FEELS THAT WOULD LEAD
TO BETTER PLANTERS ALIENS
DISEASE MANAGEMENT ETCETERA --
WHAT WE'VE HARD THAT UC'S ARE
DOING THIS RESEARCH BUT THERE
NEED TO BE STAFF WITH THIS KIND
OF BASS EXPERTISE?
IN THE DEPARTMENT WHO CAN
ACTUALLY OPERATIONALIZE THAT
RESEARCH IT'S ONE THING TO DO
THE RESEARCH AND IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO IMPLEMENTED AND IF WE
DON'T HAVE EXPERT STAFF TO
IMPLEMENTED IN THE DEPARTMENT.
THAT RESEARCH DOESN'T GO VERY
FAR WHICH IS WHY WE SAY THAT
ALONG WITH DOING WHATEVER PEST
CONTROL YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW
YOU DEFINITELY NEED TO PLEASE
ADD MONEY FOR INCREASED STAFFING
AT CDFA. FOR SPECIAL EXPORTS TO
TO INCREASE PLANT RESILIENCE FOR
CITRUS AS WELL AS DISEASE
MANAGEMENT THANK YOU.
HELLO ALISON JOHNSON FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
ON ISSUE ELEVEN WITH RESPECT --
TO CITRUS GREENING I WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF THE PESTICIDE ACTION NETWORK.
ON ENERGY SEE SUPPORTS LONG TERM
PLANNING TO ADDRESS SUCH A
SCREENING -- AND SIMILARLY
BELIEVES THAT THE DEPARTMENT ON
BUDGET ALLOCATION SHOULD INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO SUPPORT
PLANT RESILIENCE AND DISEASE
DISEASE MANAGEMENT.
INCLUDING AN EMPHASIS ON
CONTROLS THAT ARE COMPATIBLE
WITH ORGANIC AGRICULTURE.
ON ISSUE FOURTEEN I'D LIKE TO
RAISE A COUPLE OF ISSUES RELATED
TO IMPLEMENTATION OF SENATE BILL
TWENTY SEVEN WHICH WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
INTENDED TO FIGHT THE GROWING
ANTIBIOTIC RESISTANCE CRISIS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ON THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S OVERSIGHT OF THE
DEBATES IMPLEMENTATION EFFORTS
AND BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT HAS
MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TOWARD
FULFILLING THE COMMITMENTS THAT.
ON THE DEPARTMENT NEED TO THIS
COMMITTEE DURING THE BUDGET
PROCESS LAST YEAR.
HOWEVER THERE ARE -- TWO MEAN
ISSUES THAT REMAIN UNRESOLVED IN
WE'D APPRECIATE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE'S CONTINUED
ATTENTION TO THEM -- THOSE ARE
ANNUAL REPORTING BY CFA ON ITS
COLLECTION OF VETERINARY FEED
DIRECTIVES AND ON A PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE PLAN FOR COLLECTING
REPRESENTATIVE ANTIBIOTICS SALES
USE DATA.
ESPECIALLY IF THE DEPARTMENT
CONTINUES -- TO RELY ON
VOLUNTARY SURVEYS AS A PRIMARY
SOURCE OF ANTIBIOTIC USE DATA.
ON WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE MONITORING THESE ISSUES
AS THEY CONSIDER SEE IF ITS
BUDGET -- BETWEEN NOW AND JUNE
THANK YOU -- WELCOME BACK WAS A
TURN GOOD MORNING AND TO THE
COMMITTEE AS WELL -- I'LL
FEATHER THEM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY --
AND I WILL ALSO BE ALIGNING ON
ONE CALIFORNIA WITH THESE
COMMENTS -- FIRST WANT TO START
BY MY I WILL BE COMMENTING ON
ISSUE NUMBER. TEN BY DIVERSE
INITIATIVE. FOR SOMEONE TO
SURVIVE BUT THINKING SECRETARY
ROSS AND HER STAFF FOR MAKING
THEMSELVES -- VERY MUCH
AVAILABLE TO US TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH C. M. P.
S. WITH MIDLAND SOCIETY ABOUT
THE SPIDER VERSION INITIATIVE.
SOMETHING THAT THAT'S THE NPS
HAS BEEN VERY INTIMATELY
INVOLVED WITH -- FROM THE GROUND
FLOOR -- GOING BACK A COUPLE
YEARS WORKING WITH THE PRIOR --
ADMINISTRATION WITH GOVERNOR
BROWN THEN GOVERNOR BROWN --
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE OVERALL
INTENT OF THE B. C. P. -- AND
AND THE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
REALLY BEEN FOCUSED ON ON THE
FACT THAT WE DO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA POINT RESCUE WHICH AS
MISS REYES POINTED OUT THERE
ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH BEING ABLE
TO CATALOG AND AND AND SEED SEED
BANK -- HALF OF THE REST OF THE
RARE PLANTS IN CALIFORNIA -- AS
AS A GLOBAL BIODIVERSITY HUTS
BUT I THINK IT CAN'T BE.
OVERSTATED HOW IMPORTANT THIS
THIS THE BANKING PROJECT IS FOR
CALIFORNIA -- ESPECIALLY WHEN
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET US TO ON A PERCENT
OF SEEPING KING OF THE RAREST
PLANS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'LL TAKE US ABOUT TWO MILLION
MORE DOLLARS. ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO DO THE ACTUAL
COLLECTION AND THE CATALOGUING
AND ANOTHER -- HALF A MILLION TO
TO UPDATE AND UPGRADE SOME OF
THE THE FACILITIES AND AND AND
THE THE TOOLS THAT YOU USED TO
TO ACTION CONSERVE THEM LONG
TERM -- AND WHAT THAT
FUNCTIONALLY MEANS IS THAT IF
CALIFORNIANS ABLE TO TO GET THAT
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION DOLLARS
OUT THE DOOR I'M TO DO THIS WORK --
WE WILL HAVE PREVENTED PLANT
EXTINCTION IN CALIFORNIA MOVING
FORWARD -- WHICH I THINK IS IS A
VERY -- I MEAN FOR FOR ME
PERSONALLY THAT THE THAT SAYS A
LOT ABOUT CALIFORNIA'S --
PRIORITIZATION OF OUR BY
DIVERSITY IN OUR NATIVE -- FLORA --
WE'LL WE'LL GET TO THE FINAL
LATER ON BUT JUST REALLY WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT AND THAT WE ARE
ENCOURAGED BY -- AND SUPPORT
LEAVING THE ITEM OPEN TO ALLOW
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO WORK WITH WITH THE
SECRETARY ON RUSS'S STAFF AT CFA --
TO TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT LOOKS
LIKE MOVE FORWARD AND VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THE WORKING GROUP
COMING TOGETHER AND AND
BEGINNING. TO TO TO GET TO WORK
ON CONTINUING TO IMPLEMENT THEIR
THE BY DIVERSITY INITIATIVE --
WHICH WAS INITIATED BY THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT WAS
RELEASED LAST SEPTEMBER THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR AND AND COMMITTEE -- I'M
DOUG JOHNSON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
INVASIVE PLANT COUNCIL -- ALSO
COMMENTING ON ITEM NUMBER.
TEN WHERE I STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORT.
AND PRIVATE LAND MANAGERS
WORKING TO PROTECT THE STATE
FROM THE STATE'S ENVIRONMENT.
AND ECONOMY FROM INVASIVE PLANTS.
AND I AM SPEAKING TO THE THREE
MILLION DOLLAR PIECE OF THE
BIODIVERSITY B. C. P..
THAT WE BELIEVE AS AN EXCELLENT
AND CRITICAL INVESTMENT IN THE
STATE'S NATURAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
AND THAT IS FOR THE NOXIOUS WEED
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT.
THAT PROGRAM -- SUPPORTS
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
TAKING LOCAL ACTION TO REALLY --
MAKE SURE WE GET THINGS EARLY
WHICH IS CRITICAL TO PROTECT OUR
BIODIVERSITY.
IT ALSO PROTECTS -- RECREATION
AND WILDLIFE FIRE SAFETY WATER
RESOURCES AND OF COURSE
AGRICULTURE AS WELL SO WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THAT B. C. B. ITEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MATTEO CROW ON
BEHALF THE PENINSULA OPEN SPACE
TRUST AND SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN SPACE AUTHORITY -- ALSO
SPEAKING TO ISSUE TEN ARM IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BC PM WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL HERE ON
ITEM NUMBER -- ELEVEN BUT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE B. C. P. AND
BRINGING DEDICATED STAFF TO SEE
A FACE ADDRESS PROGRAM WE ALSO
APPRECIATE -- THE COMMITTEE
HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN AS A
SECRETARY ROSS SAID AS THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF DOING.
THIS PROGRAM THIS PAST AND THIS
DISEASE IS ONLY EXPANDING THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE NOW FOUND OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED TREES WITH THE
DISEASE.
IS SCARY ESPECIALLY TO THE
CITRUS INDUSTRY AND PROTECTING
THAT INDUSTRY -- FORTUNATELY IS
BEEN CONTAINED TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT RECENTLY WE JUST
FOUND ACP HEARING SACRAMENTO AND
WE NOW HAVE A QUARANTINE HERE --
SO THE BUG IS IS ON THE MOVE
WHICH MAKES IS CONCERNED THAT
THE DISEASE IS ALSO ON THE MOVE --
WE THINK THAT WE NEED TO TAKE A
GOOD LOOK AT HOW MUCH STAFF IS
NEED TO BE DEDICATED THEIR MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH FOR THE
FUTURE AS THE STAFF MAY NEED TO
GROW WITH THIS PROGRAM -- I'D
ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT YOU KNOW
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME CONCERNS
RAISED ABOUT -- TO SEE IF HE'S
PROGRAM CDFA HAS A FANTASTIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE INDUSTRY
AND I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE PAST PREVENTION PROGRAM IS
REALLY FOR FOCUSED ON THOSE
URBAN SOUNDS.
AND ENSURING THAT WERE
CONTAINING THE BAG IN THE
DISEASE AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE --
THAT GOES TOWARDS A HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT INCLUDES EDUCATION
INCLUDES REMOVAL OF TREES
INCLUDES TREATMENT -- AND CDFA
HAS BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON THAT
AND HAS BEEN DOING AN EXCELLENT
JOB ON THAT WITH THE HELP OF THE
INDUSTRY FINDS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMING IN EACH YEAR.
WHEN IT COMES -- TO TREATMENTS
OF GROWERS THAT'S COMPLETELY ON
THE GROWERS THAT'S NOT CDS PHASE
RESPONSIBILITY SO WHETHER IT'S
AN ORGANIC FARMER CONVENTIONAL
FARMER.
THAT'S UP TO THE FARMER TO BE
INSURING THAT THEY'RE PROTECTING
THEIR GROVE CDFA IS FOCUSED ON
THAT URBAN EDUCATION TREATMENT.
AND REMOVAL OF TREES -- FURTHER
WITH RESEARCH -- UC RIVERSIDE --
WHAT THE INDUSTRY ACTUALLY
DEDICATED TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
BUILD A STATE OF THE ART
FACILITY?
AT UC RIVERSIDE SPECIFICALLY
TOWARDS RESEARCH TO FIND TRY TO
FIND A CURE AND THEY WORK
CLOSELY WITH CDFA TO ENSURE THAT
THIS RESEARCH IS BEING SHARED
AND WITH OTHER UC'S WITH FLORIDA
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT TEN
MILLION.
INDUSTRY CONTINUES TO PUT IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO ENSURE
THAT THAT RESEARCH FACILITY HAS
THE RESOURCES NEEDED TO FIND THE
RESEARCH BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WE
DO.
WANT TO FIND A SOLUTION WE DON'T
WANT TO HAVE TO KEEP.
TREATING TREES AND PULLING OUT
PEOPLE'S TREES THAT YOU KNOW
THEIR GRANDFATHER MAY HAVE
PLANTED OR THINGS LIKE THAT SO
THERE IS RESEARCH BEING DONE.
SEDIA PHASE PROGRAM IS DOING AN
EXCELLENT JOB IN VERY IMPORTANT
JOB AND THEN THE COMMERCIAL
GROWERS.
ARE HERE TO CONTINUE THAT
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE STATE --
CDFA AND ALL THOSE OTHERS THAT
ARE WORKING ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I MAY
TOUCH ON DRIVE FROM BEST ACTION
NETWORK ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIANS WITH BY SIDE
REFORM.
I FORGOT TO MENTION WHEN I SPOKE
EARLIER THAT LINE MY COMMENTS
WITHIN IDC ON THEIR POSITION ON
ANTIBIOTICS.
SO JUST WANT TO PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD.
THANK YOU RESEARCH I JUST WOULD
LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT WE WILL BE
ISSUING AN ANNUAL REPORT ON OUR
ANTIBIOTIC PROGRAM THAT'S DUE IN
JUNE WE DID AN INITIAL REPORT.
OF THE START UP OF THE PROGRAM
THAT WAS RELEASED IN JANUARY BUT
THERE WEALTHY ON GOING REPORTS
THAT'S PART OF OUR OBLIGATION OF
THE NEXT REPORTERS JUNE.
JUNE I THINK IS THE RIGHT -- ONE
BUT WHAT I CAN FROM THAT BUT I
THINK IT'S BY THE END OF THIS
FISCAL YEAR GREAT THANK YOU.
WE HAVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION YOU DON'T HAVE
TO STICK AROUND IF YOU DON'T
WANT -- TO I'M SURE YOU THERE'S
NOTHING YOU'D RATHER DO -- HOME
BUT MISTER MALONE HAS A COUPLE
OF ADD ONS AND MISTER PATTERSON
CAN BE FOUND AT ON ITEMS WE
HEARD ISSUES FIVE THROUGH NINE
ALL OF PARKS AND REX ITEMS --
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE MULLIN.
ITEMS TO BE HEARD ISSUE THIRTEEN
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
THIS IS.
HE'S ON HIS WAY.
OKAY
.
LISTER PETTER SAID I THINK WE
HAVE ONE BILL FAURIA
[inaudible]
ITEMS.
ITEMS WE HEARD ISSUE THIRTEEN
TURLOCK NORTH VALLEY ANIMAL
HEALTH LABORATORY REPLACEMENT
CURRENT VOTES SIX ZERO CHAIR
VOTING AYE PATTERSON.
WE ARE ADJOURNED